We've all been there, the unexpected hosting panic. Like when the watch party finally makes it out of the group chat, but you volunteered to host, and suddenly you need snacks, drinks, dips, cups, and all the other party essentials no one else planned for. With Instacart, you can get all those groceries delivered in as fast as 60 minutes. No extra errands for you. One quick order for everyone. That way, everything shows up right on time, making hosting easy and making it look like you had it planned all along. Download the Instacard app today and get no markups at select retailers. Fees and in-store offer exclusions apply. Hello there. Welcome to your second drink of baby shower. This is the episode where we throw a
我们都经历过这种情况，那种突如其来的待客恐慌。比如当聚会终于从群聊变成现实，而你自告奋勇担任东道主，突然间你需要零食、饮料、蘸酱、杯子以及其他没人想到的派对必需品。有了 Instacart，你可以在短短 60 分钟内送达所有这些杂货。无需额外跑腿。只需为每个人快速下单。这样，一切都能准时出现，让待客变得轻松，看起来就像你一直都在计划之中。立即下载 Instacart 应用程序，在指定零售商处享受零加价优惠。费用和店内优惠排除条款适用。你好。欢迎来到你的第二杯“婴儿洗礼派对”。这是我们为简（Jan）已经出生的孩子举办婴儿洗礼派对的一集。
baby shower for Jan's baby who has already been born. We have some really great tidbits from the writer of this episode, Aaron Scher, and from Prop Master Phil Shea. And we reveal which celebrity might be Jan's sperm donor. That was a big find. It was. I don't want to ruin it, you guys, but it was really fun. There are also several moments that fans flagged as their favorite from Baby Shower. They are also delicious. Two of the most popular were when Jan Singh's son of a preacher man to the whole room. Yes.
我们从本集编剧亚伦·谢尔（Aaron Scher）和道具师菲尔·谢伊（Phil Shea）那里得到了一些非常棒的趣闻。我们还揭露了哪位名人可能是简的精子捐赠者。那是一个大发现。确实。我不想剧透，伙计们，但这真的很有趣。粉丝们还标记了几个他们最喜欢的“婴儿洗礼派对”时刻。它们也非常精彩。其中最受欢迎的两个时刻是简在整个房间里唱《牧师之子》（Son of a Preacher Man）。是的。
At the shower. And then when Dwight tests the stroller. But the big winner of the favorite moment for this episode is a deleted scene. And it is when Kevin reveals he has donated sperm to the very very. same sperm bank that Jan used, the one by IHop. Lady, you play it during our breakdown. But we also got a letter about this moment from Leah S in Germany who said, Hey, guys, amazing podcast.
在派对上。然后是德怀特（Dwight）测试婴儿车的时候。但这一集最受欢迎时刻的大赢家是一个删减片段。那是凯文（Kevin）透露他曾向简使用的同一个精子库捐赠过精子，就是IHop旁边的那家。女士，你在我们解析时播放它。但我们也收到了一封关于这个时刻的信，来自德国的莉亚·S（Leah S），她说，嘿，伙计们，很棒的播客。
My favorite scene from baby showers, actually a blooper, and I was wondering why it got cut. And also if it was improvised or in the shooting draft, it's the moment when you're in the conference room and Kevin tells Jan that he donated sperm. Then Kevin asked Jan if she got the sperm from next to the IHop and and Jan looks at him as if she wants to kill him. And in the blooper, he says, you can just let me know personally if you want it to have a brother or sister
我最喜欢的“婴儿洗礼派对”场景其实是一个花絮，我想知道为什么它被剪掉了。还有它是即兴创作的还是在拍摄剧本里的，就是你在会议室里，凯文告诉简他捐赠了精子。然后凯文问简她是不是从IHop旁边拿的精子，简看着他，好像想杀了他。在花絮里，他说，如果你想让它有个兄弟姐妹，你可以私下告诉我。
and then everybody breaks. Leah goes on to say, I think that's so funny, and I'm kind of sad it's not in the episode and also how on earth did you guys make it through that episode? Well, Leah, in the breakdown, we talk about how we couldn't get through that scene.
然后大家都笑场了。莉亚接着说，我觉得这太搞笑了，我很遗憾它没有出现在正片里，还有你们到底是怎么拍完那一集的？嗯，莉亚，在解析中，我们谈到了我们是如何无法拍完那个场景的。
Couldn't get through it. The moment Malora as Jan has the look of realization that it's the same sperm pain. Yes. Every time got me. But I will tell you, this entire scene was scripted. It was not improvised. And Leah, you will be happy to know that it has all been added back to the superfan version
拍不下去。当玛洛拉（Melora）饰演的简意识到那是同一个精子库时的表情。是的。每次都让我笑场。但我得告诉你，整个场景都是有剧本的。它不是即兴创作的。莉亚，你会很高兴知道它已经被加回了超级粉丝版本中。
of Baby Shower for all to see. I'm so glad it made it back in. Another fan favorite moment came in from Brianna E. from Illinois. She says the suburbs of Illinois. My favorite part was when Michael was explaining what it would be like to have a baby as a president. This is a really fun talking head. We didn't play it before. It's one of those classic Michael moments where he makes a declaration before he's really thought it through, and then he kind of has to bail.
让所有人都能看到“婴儿洗礼派对”。我很高兴它被加回来了。另一个粉丝最喜欢的时刻来自伊利诺伊州的布里安娜·E（Brianna E）。她说伊利诺伊州的郊区。我最喜欢的部分是迈克尔（Michael）解释如果婴儿当总统会是什么样子。这是一个非常有趣的谈话头（talking head）。我们之前没放过。这是迈克尔的经典时刻之一，他在没深思熟虑之前就发表了声明，然后他不得不找借口脱身。
Let's all hear it. I love babies. I think they are beautiful in all sorts of different ways. I try to pick up and hold a baby every day, if possible, because it nourished. me. It feeds my soul. Babies are drawn to me. And I think it's because they see me as one of them. But cooler and with my life put together a little bit. If a baby were president, there would be no taxes. There would be no war. There would be no government. And things could get terrible. It actually probably would be a better screenplay idea.
让我们听听看。我爱婴儿。我觉得他们在各方面都很美。如果可能的话，我每天都试着抱抱婴儿，因为它滋养了我。它滋养了我的灵魂。婴儿被我吸引。我想这是因为他们把我视为他们的一员。但更酷，而且我的生活更有条理一点。如果婴儿当总统，就不会有税收。就不会有战争。就不会有政府。事情可能会变得很糟糕。这实际上可能是一个更好的剧本构思。
screenplay idea than a serious suggestion. I could see Michael writing the screenplay for like baby president and it would be like a look who's talking thing. He'd do the voice of the baby. Oh yeah. He thinks it would be so funny and the baby would have a little tiny suit on. Yep. Have a little oval office. All right. This next letter comes from Soyan in South Korea. In the scene where the PPC and Michael are preparing the baby shower, they prepared two bowls of personalized M&M. One said Chevy, if it's a boy, and Michael said, that's me, which sounds like he picked the name. Well, I just realized that Jan must have known the gender of the baby in advance without telling Michael, and that's why she let him pick the boy name.
剧本构思，而不是严肃的建议。我能想象迈克尔写《婴儿总统》的剧本，就像《看谁在说话》那种东西。他会给婴儿配音。哦，是的。他觉得这会非常有趣，而且婴儿会穿着一件小小的西装。是的。有一个小小的椭圆形办公室。好了。下一封信来自韩国的素妍（Soyan）。在PPC（派对策划委员会）和迈克尔准备婴儿洗礼派对的场景中，他们准备了两碗个性化的M&M豆。一碗写着“Chevy”，如果是男孩的话，迈克尔说，那是我的名字，听起来像是他选的名字。嗯，我刚意识到简一定提前知道了孩子的性别，但没告诉迈克尔，这就是为什么她让他选男孩的名字。
What do you think? I love you, ladies. I so agree. Right? I so agree. So, Jan, I went to the candy bag alts for this episode, and there are a bunch of talking heads where Michael talks about picking the name Chevy and why. And then there is this one that was actually added back to the superfan episode that pretty much proves your theory.
你们怎么看？我爱你们，女士们。我太同意了。对吧？我太同意了。所以，简，我看了这一集的糖果袋花絮，里面有一堆谈话头，迈克尔谈到了选“Chevy”这个名字的原因。然后有一个实际上被加回超级粉丝剧集里的片段，几乎证明了你的理论。
Let's listen. Jan knows a sex, but she's not telling me. She did say that I could pick out a boy name. Her exact words were, knock yourself out. She's like, sure. Go for it. Because I know I'm having a girl and I'm naming her Astrid. Exactly. Well, everyone, there you go. And please enjoy your second drink of baby shower. Thank you all for writing in with your favorite baby shower moments. You can submit more of your favorite episode moments for our second drinks at office ladies.com. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on the office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of the office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes story.
让我们听听。简知道性别，但她没告诉我。她确实说我可以选一个男孩的名字。她的原话是，“随你便”。她就像是，当然，去吧。因为我知道我怀的是个女孩，我给她取名叫阿斯特丽德（Astrid）。没错。好了，各位，就是这样。请享受你们的第二杯“婴儿洗礼派对”。谢谢大家写信分享你们最喜欢的“婴儿洗礼派对”时刻。你们可以在officeladies.com提交更多你们最喜欢的剧集时刻，供我们作为第二杯饮品讨论。我是珍娜·费舍尔（Jenna Fischer）。我是安吉拉·金赛（Angela Kinsey）。我们一起出演了《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你进行终极《办公室》重温播客。每周，我们都会解析一集《办公室》，并提供独家幕后故事。
that only two people who were there can tell you. We're the office ladies. Are you ready for a baby shower? I sure am. It's Jan's baby shower today. At a company she no longer works at, with a man she no longer dates and is not the father of her baby. It's going to be a huge success. Oh yeah. Yeah. All the elements are there. Right? Yes. People she doesn't really like are throwing her a baby shower. And they don't like her. It's going to be great. It's season And five, episode four. This episode was written by Aaron Shore and directed by Greg Daniels. I have a summary. Let's do it. Michael and the party planning committee still headed by Phyllis throw a baby shower for Jan.
只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你。我们是“办公室女士”。你准备好参加婴儿洗礼派对了吗？我当然准备好了。今天是简的婴儿洗礼派对。在一家她不再工作的公司，和一个她不再约会且不是她孩子父亲的男人一起。这会是一个巨大的成功。哦，是的。是的。所有元素都在那里。对吧？是的。她并不真正喜欢的人正在为她举办婴儿洗礼派对。而他们也不喜欢她。这会很棒。这是第五季第四集。这一集由亚伦·谢尔（Aaron Shore）编剧，格雷格·丹尼尔斯（Greg Daniels）导演。我有一个摘要。我们开始吧。迈克尔和仍然由菲利斯（Phyllis）领导的派对策划委员会为简举办了婴儿洗礼派对。
But they are unaware that she has already given birth to her daughter Astrid. Jan's presence in the office causes Michael to be rude to Holly and Dwight spends the day putting Jan's luxury stroller to the test. Meanwhile, Jim and Pam feel the effects of their long-distance relationship. Oh, that was hard to watch. They were out of sync. They were. You don't like to see that. No, I don't.
但他们不知道她已经生下了女儿阿斯特丽德。简在办公室的出现导致迈克尔对霍莉（Holly）很粗鲁，而德怀特花了一整天时间测试简的豪华婴儿车。与此同时，吉姆（Jim）和帕姆（Pam）感受到了异地恋的影响。哦，那很难看。他们不同步。他们确实不同步。你不喜欢看到那样。不，我不喜欢。
Fast fact number one. New writer alert. Aaron sure joined the writing staff this year in season five. Aaron had been a writer on Everybody Loves Raymond, which is one of my favorite sitcoms of all time. It is such a great ensemble sitcom. Do you know that one where Marie goes to art class? and she makes the sculpture. And then, guys, look it up.
快讯第一条。新编剧警报。亚伦·谢尔今年加入了第五季的编剧团队。亚伦曾是《人人都爱雷蒙德》（Everybody Loves Raymond）的编剧，这是我最喜欢的电视情景喜剧之一。那是一部非常棒的群戏情景喜剧。你知道玛丽（Marie）去上艺术课的那一集吗？她做了一个雕塑。然后，伙计们，去查查。
She makes a sculpture and she's so proud and she unveils it and it looks like a vagina. But she doesn't know. But everybody else is like, Marie, what inspired you to make this piece? Oh, my gosh. It's so good. Her character was so good. So anyway, I was very excited to have Erin join the writing staff because then I could ask him tons of questions about everybody loves Raymond. And you did.
她做了一个雕塑，她非常自豪，她揭开了它，它看起来像个阴道。但她不知道。但其他人都在说，玛丽，是什么启发你创作了这个作品？哦，天哪。太棒了。她的角色太棒了。总之，我很高兴亚伦加入编剧团队，因为这样我就可以问他关于《人人都爱雷蒙德》的无数问题。你确实问了。
I did. You chatted him up a lot about it. Well, we have some news. Angela, do you want to share? I do. So I reached out to Aaron. We had been trying to get a hold of him. You slid into his DMs.
我问了。你和他聊了很多关于那个的话题。嗯，我们有一些消息。安吉拉，你想分享吗？我想。所以我联系了亚伦。我们一直试图联系他。你滑进了他的私信（DMs）。
I did. He was like, I don't even know. Do I have DMs? I'm like, yes. But I found an old email, and we got in touch, and it was so fun to talk to him. He's a huge fan of the podcast. Jenna, he told me that he listens to the podcast in the evenings. And then sometimes when he drifts off to sleep, he dreams, like, that he's in the podcast with us.
我确实滑了。他当时说，我甚至不知道。我有私信吗？我说，有的。但我找到了一封旧邮件，我们取得了联系，和他聊天非常有趣。他是这个播客的忠实粉丝。珍娜，他告诉我他晚上会听这个播客。然后有时当他昏昏欲睡时，他会梦见自己和我们一起在播客里。
Oh, my goodness is that. Is that a good dream or a nightmare? I don't know. I hope it's a good thing. I hope so. Erin had lots of great stuff to share. We're going to hit him up quite a bit. We have Aaron now. We have James and also Randy Cordrick. Yes. When Angela told me that she got a hold of Aaron, I know you were going to ask him about the office, but I had an Everybody Loves Raymond question. Still, this poor man, I cornered him on set and now you're calling him on the phone. And my question is still about everybody loves Raymond. But here's the thing. I remember that there was this episode that was based on a story from his real life, but I couldn't remember all the details. It's the episode.
哦，天哪，那是。那是好梦还是噩梦？我不知道。我希望是件好事。我希望如此。亚伦有很多很棒的东西可以分享。我们要经常找他。我们现在有亚伦了。我们有詹姆斯（James），还有兰迪·科德里克（Randy Cordrick）。是的。当安吉拉告诉我她联系上了亚伦时，我知道你会问他关于《办公室》的事，但我有一个关于《人人都爱雷蒙德》的问题。还是那个可怜的人，我在片场堵住了他，现在你又在电话里找他。我的问题还是关于《人人都爱雷蒙德》。但问题是。我记得有一集是基于他真实生活中的故事，但我记不清所有细节了。那一集。
It's called 10th anniversary, and Ray and Deborah are celebrating their 10th anniversary, and they want to watch their wedding tape, and they get it out, and they put it in the VCR, they press play, and Ray has recorded a football game over their wedding tape. And I remember that there is some story where I think Aaron recorded over his wedding tape with his wife. That is true. I knew it. That is true. So this is what happened.
叫《十周年》，雷（Ray）和黛博拉（Deborah）正在庆祝他们的十周年纪念日，他们想看他们的婚礼录像带，他们把它拿出来，放进录像机，按下播放键，雷在他们的婚礼录像带上录了一场橄榄球比赛。我记得有一个故事，我想亚伦在他的婚礼录像带上录了东西。那是真的。我就知道。那是真的。所以发生了这样的事。
Okay. So Aaron was a fan of Everybody Loves Raymond. It was a show he wanted to meet on. So he thought, oh, I'll record a few episodes, watch them, really study the show. So when I go in and meet, you know, I have all this information. So he popped in a VHS. Guys, this dates us all a little bit. And he hit record.
好吧。所以亚伦是《人人都爱雷蒙德》的粉丝。那是他想去面试的节目。所以他想，哦，我会录几集，看看，好好研究一下这个节目。所以当我进去面试时，你知道，我有所有这些信息。所以他塞进了一盘录像带。伙计们，这让我们都有点显老了。他按下了录制键。
And it was his wedding video. Yeah. And back then, you guys, it's not like you have multiple copies. Like you get your wedding videotape and that's it. Yeah. Yeah. His wife was really upset. Oh, no. And he went in to meet on Everybody Loves Raymond and he told that story. He was like, I taped over my wedding video to watch Everybody Loves Raymond. So my wife is really mad. You've got to give me this job. And he got the job. And then that story made it into an episode. Yes. I love it. A lot of Aaron's life ends up in scripts, you guys. There's a few episodes coming up that his actual life inspired things that Michael does, and I can't wait to share those with you. I'm so glad we're in touch with him. I know. Fast fact number two.
那是他的婚礼录像。是的。在那个年代，伙计们，不像现在你有多个副本。就像你拿到你的婚礼录像带，就是这样。是的。是的。他妻子非常生气。哦，不。他去面试《人人都爱雷蒙德》，他讲了那个故事。他说，我录了《人人都爱雷蒙德》覆盖了我的婚礼录像。所以我妻子很生气。你必须给我这份工作。他得到了这份工作。然后那个故事被写进了一集里。是的。我喜欢它。亚伦的很多生活最终都写进了剧本里，伙计们。接下来有几集，他的真实生活启发了迈克尔做的事情，我迫不及待地想和你们分享。我很高兴我们和他保持联系。我知道。快讯第二条。
Angela, we shot this episode in August of 2008. And since we brought it up before, I thought it was worth mentioning that this same month, Steve Correll, won his second surfboard at the 2008. Teen Choice Awards for TV comedy actor. Steve, where did you put your surfboards? Back to pack surfboards. Wow. When we have him on the podcast, is it going to be weird if we ask him where his surfboards are?
安吉拉，我们是在2008年8月拍摄这一集的。既然我们之前提到了，我觉得值得一提的是，就在同一个月，史蒂夫·卡瑞尔（Steve Carell）在2008年青少年选择奖上凭借电视喜剧男演员奖赢得了他的第二个冲浪板奖杯。史蒂夫，你把你的冲浪板放在哪了？背靠背冲浪板。哇。当他来参加我们的播客时，如果我们问他冲浪板在哪里，会很奇怪吗？
It depends where you put him. It's going to be such a weird question. Well, also this same year, the movie Juno won Best Comedy Movie, and Rain Wilson was in that. Also, this same year, we won a SAG Award. Yes. So this was like the awards and the surfboards were coming in now. Yeah. Right?
这取决于你把它放在哪。那会是一个非常奇怪的问题。嗯，同样在这一年，电影《朱诺》（Juno）获得了最佳喜剧电影奖，雷恩·威尔森（Rainn Wilson）也参演了。同样在这一年，我们赢得了演员工会奖（SAG Award）。是的。所以这就像奖项和冲浪板现在都来了。是的。对吧？
It was really cool. And I remember at the 2008 SAG Awards, we were sitting at the table and everybody was like, who's going to give the speech if we win? And we all assumed it would be Steve, like Steve will give the speech. And Steve said, guys, this is an ensemble. I don't want to always speak for the cast. That doesn't feel right to me. This is an ensemble award. I think someone else should speak.
这真的很酷。我记得在2008年演员工会奖上，我们坐在桌子旁，每个人都在说，如果我们赢了，谁来发表获奖感言？我们都以为会是史蒂夫，就像史蒂夫会发表感言一样。史蒂夫说，伙计们，这是一个群戏。我不想总是代表剧组发言。这对我来说感觉不对。这是一个群戏奖。我认为应该由其他人发言。
And I mean, first of all, amazing. right? He's so sweet. Awesome. And so then Rain said, I think Jenna should do it. And I feel like none of us really thought we were going to win because we'd won the year before. And I said, oh, okay, yeah, sure, I'll do it. And then we won. And I had to give a speech at an award show. And you did such a great job. You were so articulate and well spoken. I was in awe because we didn't think we were going to win. No. It was a total surprise. And then we won. And I'm like walking to the stage and I'm like, Oh my God. Well, I know you guys are tired of me talking about being pregnant, but I was pregnant at that award show.
我的意思是，首先，太棒了。对吧？他太贴心了。太棒了。所以雷恩说，我认为珍娜应该去做。我觉得我们都没想过我们会赢，因为我们前一年刚赢过。我说，哦，好吧，是的，当然，我会做的。然后我们赢了。我不得不在颁奖典礼上发表感言。你做得太棒了。你表达得非常清晰，口才很好。我很敬畏，因为我们没想过我们会赢。不。这完全是个惊喜。然后我们赢了。我走上舞台，心想，天哪。好吧，我知道你们厌倦了我谈论怀孕的事，但我当时在那个颁奖典礼上怀孕了。
And it's a very odd thing to be super huge and pregnant at an award show. But you did such a great job. Thank you. I ended up kind of going down a rabbit hole of all the, like, cool things that happened for our show in 2008. It was a good year. It was a good year. James Carey sent me the call sheet for this episode. Jamesopedia.
在颁奖典礼上挺着大肚子是一件非常奇怪的事情。但你做得太棒了。谢谢。我最终陷入了关于我们节目在2008年发生的所有酷事的兔子洞。那是美好的一年。那是美好的一年。詹姆斯·凯里（James Carey）发给我了这一集的通告单。詹姆斯百科（Jamesopedia）。
Jamesopedia. And on the call sheet, it said, there is a screening of Rain Wilson's new movie The Rocker at Universal City Walk for the cast and crew. All are welcome. So that was also happening. That's a lot happening. All right. Fast fact number three. This episode is a baby shower. So I'm going to tell you some stuff about baby showers. You did a deep dive on baby showers? I did. What is there to know? It's a baby coming. Get some presents. Get everyone ready. What else is there to know? Well, baby showers are believed to date all the way back to the Egyptian and Greek civilizations.
詹姆斯百科。在通告单上，它写着，在环球城市大道（Universal City Walk）为演职人员举办雷恩·威尔森的新电影《摇滚青春》（The Rocker）的放映会。欢迎所有人参加。所以那也在发生。发生的事情太多了。好了。快讯第三条。这一集是婴儿洗礼派对。所以我打算告诉你们一些关于婴儿洗礼派对的事情。你对婴儿洗礼派对做了深入研究？我做了。有什么好知道的？婴儿要来了。准备些礼物。让每个人准备好。还有什么好知道的？嗯，婴儿洗礼派对被认为可以追溯到埃及和希腊文明。
Whoa! But baby showers, as we know them today, began during the baby boom era of World War II. So traditionally, the baby shower was thrown by a close family member or a friend, and the mother-to-be opened gifts in a decorated chair. Well, Jan has a very decorated chair. I noticed. Yeah, thank you party planning committee. Thank you, Phyllis. Well, I think Angela did it because Phyllis is making her do everything.
哇！但我们今天所知的婴儿洗礼派对始于二战后的婴儿潮时期。所以传统上，婴儿洗礼派对是由亲密的家庭成员或朋友举办的，准妈妈会在一把装饰过的椅子上拆礼物。嗯，简有一把装饰得非常漂亮的椅子。我注意到了。是的，谢谢派对策划委员会。谢谢菲利斯。嗯，我想安吉拉做了，因为菲利斯让她做所有事。
So thank you, Angela. Okay. I don't know. Well, listen, nowadays, we have all kinds of ways that we can celebrate a new baby. And here are some new updated baby showers, a diaper shower. That's where all you bring are diapers in different sizes. It's like if you go to your baby shower, it's like you went to Costco and bought out all the diapers. You just go home with every diaper because diapers are expensive.
所以谢谢安吉拉。好吧。我不知道。嗯，听着，现在，我们有各种各样的方式来庆祝新婴儿。这里有一些新的更新的婴儿洗礼派对，尿布派对。那就是你带的全部东西就是不同尺寸的尿布。就像如果你去参加婴儿洗礼派对，就像你去了Costco把所有的尿布都买光了一样。你回家时带着所有的尿布，因为尿布很贵。
What's the next one? Grandparents shower. This is a shower that you throw for the grandparents and you give them stuff to keep at their house for when the baby comes over. Boo. I'm saying, I love you, grandparents, but come on. Grandparents, they love to go get that stuff. Yeah, I don't know. Here's another one.
下一个是什么？祖父母派对。这是一个为你举办的派对，给祖父母，你给他们东西放在他们家里，以便婴儿过来时使用。嘘。我说，我爱你们，祖父母，但拜托。祖父母，他们喜欢去买那些东西。是的，我不知道。这里还有另一个。
I've heard of these, a sprinkle. What? You don't have a baby shower. You have a sprinkle. Sounds like you're going. It does. This is a shower that you throw for your second or third or fourth babies to collect maybe some of the things if you are having a baby of a different gender. Right, right. Or if you need to refresh. Oh, my God, I just got it. A shower and a sprinkle. Yeah. It's not a full shower. It's just a sprinkle. Every time you say it, I just think of tinkling. I do too. All right. The final one is a sip and see. Does this involve wine?
我听说过这些，撒花派对（a sprinkle）。什么？你没有婴儿洗礼派对。你有一个撒花派对。听起来像你要去。确实。这是一个为你第二个、第三个或第四个孩子举办的派对，用来收集一些东西，也许如果你怀的是不同性别的孩子。对，对。或者如果你需要更新。哦，天哪，我刚明白。洗礼派对（shower）和撒花派对（sprinkle）。是的。这不是一个完整的洗礼派对。这只是一个撒花派对。每次你说它，我就想到小便。我也一样。好了。最后一个是“啜饮与观看”（sip and see）。这涉及葡萄酒吗？
It does. It is a celebration planned by the new parents after the baby has arrived. Oh, you sip and you get to see the baby. Yes, so I have to say what we are going to see in this episode is technically a sippancy. You know what? I have been to a sippancy, but I didn't even know it. I love the name sippancy. Sippancy. Can I have a sippancy for my new puppy? Can I do that? Yes. Okay, good. That's all I got, Ange. Anything you want?
确实涉及。这是新父母在婴儿出生后计划的庆祝活动。哦，你啜饮，然后你就能看到婴儿。是的，所以我必须说，我们在这一集中看到的从技术上讲是一个“啜饮与观看”。你知道吗？我参加过一个“啜饮与观看”，但我甚至不知道。我喜欢“啜饮与观看”这个名字。啜饮与观看。我可以为我的新小狗举办一个“啜饮与观看”吗？我可以那样做吗？是的。好的，太好了。这就是我所有的了，安吉（Ange）。你有什么想补充的吗？
want to add you of a Kinsey Tidbit? Well, here's a little Kinsey Tidbit. One of the things Aaron said, which we have talked about before, is how long these scripts came in. You know, they were pretty big episodes, and then we would have to just chisel away, and there was so much that didn't make it to the screen. For example, this episode came in at 49 pages, right? Wait, what? The script for this was 49 pages? Yeah, 49 pages. That's craziness. And you know how we've talked about, about how they would sort of rebuild the episodes in editing. Well, Aaron had this quote that I absolutely loved. He said that Greg liked to rebuild the ship at sea. Oh, yeah. Is that such a great phrase? I love that. I just love that. They would get in the editor's room, man,
想补充一个金赛趣闻吗？嗯，这是一个小金赛趣闻。亚伦说的一件事，我们之前谈过，就是这些剧本有多长。你知道，它们是相当大的剧集，然后我们不得不削减，有很多东西没能出现在屏幕上。例如，这一集有49页，对吧？等等，什么？这一集的剧本有49页？是的，49页。太疯狂了。你知道我们谈过他们如何在剪辑中重建剧集。嗯，亚伦有一句我非常喜欢的名言。他说格雷格喜欢在海上重建这艘船。哦，是的。那是一个很棒的短语吗？我喜欢那个。我只是喜欢那个。他们会进入剪辑室，伙计，
and they would just carve it up. And I told him, I said, it's always interesting for me now that we have all these scripts. Thank you, James, to see what makes it on the screen and what doesn't and how they move everything around. And I'm always so happy with the final product, you know? Mm-hmm. But it's a cool thing to see. But I thought that Greg likes to rebuild the ship at sea was like a great phrase. Well, I think those were really good fast facts.
他们会把它切开。我告诉他，我说，现在我们有了所有这些剧本，对我来说总是很有趣，看看什么能出现在屏幕上，什么不能，以及他们如何移动所有东西。我总是对最终产品感到非常满意，你知道吗？嗯。但看到这个很酷。但我认为格雷格喜欢在海上重建这艘船是一个很棒的短语。嗯，我认为那些是非常好的快讯。
And we've got some more errand tidbits. We should take a break and get into this episode. I like it. This episode is sponsored by BetterHelp. I've been thinking a lot lately about how important it is to take care of our mental health, not just when things feel overwhelming, but as part of everyday life. Therapy really isn't just for crisis moments. It's a tool. Yeah, I've seen how powerful it can be.
我们还有更多亚伦的趣闻。我们应该休息一下，进入这一集。我喜欢。这一集由BetterHelp赞助。我最近一直在思考照顾我们的心理健康有多重要，不仅仅是在事情感到不知所措时，而是作为日常生活的一部分。治疗真的不仅仅是为了危机时刻。它是一个工具。是的，我已经看到了它有多强大。
But I also know that finding time for therapy can be really tricky. And that's why we love BetterHelp. Everything is online so you can schedule sessions by phone, video, or even message chat. They have the largest and most diverse network of therapists over 30,000, covering everything from anxiety and depression to stress and relationship issues. And here's the thing, if the therapist you find isn't the perfect fit for you, you can switch anytime, easily, and at no extra costs. So take a moment and prioritize your well-being with BetterHelp. Visit betterhelp.com slash office ladies to get 10% off your first month. That's BetterHelp,
但我也知道找到治疗时间可能真的很棘手。这就是为什么我们喜欢BetterHelp。一切都在线，所以你可以通过电话、视频甚至消息聊天安排会议。他们拥有最大、最多样化的治疗师网络，超过30,000名，涵盖从焦虑和抑郁到压力和关系问题的方方面面。而且是这样的，如果你找到的治疗师不适合你，你可以随时轻松切换，无需额外费用。所以花点时间，用BetterHelp优先考虑你的幸福。访问betterhelp.com/officeladies，你的第一个月可享受10%的折扣。那是BetterHelp，
H-E-L-P dot com slash office ladies. Understanding power requires more than headlines. I'm Peter Hamby, host of the Powers That Be, a podcast from Pock examining politics, economics, and media to provide context, analysis, and clarity without sensationalism. We ask how power operates, who benefits, and what's at stake. If you want to move beyond breaking news to deeper understanding, join us on the Powers That Be. New episodes every weekday, follow the Powers That Be wherever you get your podcasts. All right, we are back, and you guys, at 12 seconds, everything you need to know about this episode is laid out by Jim. Jim has a dry erase board, and he's going to tell you everything you need to know about this episode.
H-E-P点com斜杠officeladies。理解权力需要的不仅仅是头条新闻。我是彼得·汉比（Peter Hamby），《权力所在》（The Powers That Be）的主持人，这是Pock的一档播客，旨在审视政治、经济和媒体，在没有耸人听闻的情况下提供背景、分析和清晰度。我们询问权力如何运作，谁受益，以及利害关系是什么。如果你想超越突发新闻，获得更深入的理解，请加入我们的《权力所在》。每个工作日都有新剧集，在任何你获取播客的地方关注《权力所在》。好了，我们回来了，伙计们，在12秒时，吉姆列出了你需要知道的关于这一集的一切。吉姆有一个干擦板，他要告诉你关于这一集你需要知道的一切。
Sam, can you play that clip? Jan is about to have a baby with a sperm donor, and Michael is preparing for the birth of a watermelon with Dwight. Now, this baby will be related to Michael through delusion. There you go. That pretty much sums it up. That could have been the summary. I know, right? When I saw that, I was like, well, that's everything you need to know.
萨姆，你能播放那个片段吗？简即将和一个精子捐赠者生孩子，而迈克尔正在和德怀特准备生一个西瓜。现在，这个婴儿将通过妄想与迈克尔有亲戚关系。就是这样。这几乎总结了它。那本来可以作为摘要。我知道，对吧？当我看到那个时，我想，嗯，这就是你需要知道的一切。
Did you catch the Dwight? I know. I was about to say, Ann, you got a real good DeWite in there. Well, it's true. Dwight is walking around. He's got a watermelon in his smock that he's wearing. An apron? They've fastened like a smock to hold the baby.
你抓到德怀特了吗？我知道。我正要说，安，你在那里抓到了一个真正的德怀特。嗯，这是真的。德怀特走来走去。他穿着的罩衫里有一个西瓜。围裙？他们像罩衫一样系着它来抱婴儿。
Yeah, the watermelon baby. Do you have some filshay? trivia about this? I do. Yay! I talked to Phil Shea for about an hour yesterday. Prop Master extraordinaire. I know. And we are going to have him on for an extended interview because he has got just some great info and stories. I can't wait. We need to have Aaron Scher on too. We really do. Let's load it up. All right. We had a fan question from Lisa W. How many watermelons were needed to do the practice birth scene with Michael and Dwight. Phil said in total, we used about 30 watermelons for this whole episode. Oh, because he straps it into the stroller later. Yes. So for these scenes and for later.
是的，西瓜宝宝。你有关于这个的菲尔·谢伊趣闻吗？我有。耶！我昨天和菲尔·谢伊聊了一个小时。道具大师非凡。我知道。我们要请他进行一次延长的采访，因为他有一些很棒的信息和故事。我等不及了。我们也需要请亚伦·谢尔。我们真的需要。加载它。好了。我们有一个来自丽莎·W（Lisa W）的粉丝问题。练习迈克尔和德怀特的出生场景需要多少个西瓜。菲尔说总共，我们这一集用了大约30个西瓜。哦，因为他后来把它绑在婴儿车里了。是的。所以为了这些场景和以后。
And Phil said, you know, it's great living in Southern California because you can get watermelons all year. So it wasn't a problem. Okay. Yeah. Fan catch from Evelyn V said at one minute, 41 seconds, I think I can see other stains from when the watermelon crashed into the ground on previous takes. I looked at it. Evelyn, I think that's a stain from something else. I don't think it's a watermelon. I feel like as Pam, I have walked up to the front of Michael's desk and I've looked down at my feet enough in scenes. I recognize that stain. I don't know what that's from. I don't think it was watermelons. I don't know what to make of that other than maybe we should have splurge for new carpet. I think Michael needs new carpet. Yeah. We had this letter from Ben M in Chicago. I am an
菲尔说，你知道，住在南加州很棒，因为你可以全年买到西瓜。所以这不是问题。好的。是的。来自伊芙琳·V（Evelyn V）的粉丝捕捉说，在1分41秒，我想我可以看到之前拍摄时西瓜撞到地面留下的其他污渍。我看了。伊芙琳，我认为那是其他东西留下的污渍。我不认为那是西瓜。我觉得作为帕姆，我走到迈克尔办公桌前，我在场景中低头看脚的次数够多了。我认得那个污渍。我不知道那是什么。我不认为那是西瓜。除了也许我们应该挥霍买新地毯之外，我不知道该怎么处理那个。我认为迈克尔需要新地毯。是的。我们收到了这封来自芝加哥本·M（Ben M）的信。我是一名
ER doctor and whenever I'm teaching medical students how to deliver a baby, I like to show them the cold open from this episode. Get out. Yes. This reinforces to them that newborns are very slippery. Oh, come on. It helps teach them that you must always support the baby's head and neck and also hold an arm or a leg immediately after delivery. It is a very funny cold open, but also extremely accurate. Wow. Yeah. Well, Aaron told me that this whole cold open was Greg's idea, the watermelon, the whole thing. Okay. He had this whole idea, and Aaron just ran with it. It's funny you say that, because when I spoke with Phil, he said, I think Greg had an affinity for Gallagher. That's why you see so many watermelon gags on our show. That is very funny. Yeah. The comedian Gallagher. He said,
急诊室医生，每当我教医学生如何接生时，我喜欢给他们看这一集的冷开场。滚开。是的。这向他们强调了新生儿非常滑。哦，拜托。它有助于教导他们，你必须始终支撑婴儿的头部和颈部，并在分娩后立即抱住手臂或腿。这是一个非常有趣的冷开场，但也极其准确。哇。是的。嗯，亚伦告诉我整个冷开场是格雷格的主意，西瓜，整件事。好的。他有这个完整的想法，亚伦只是顺着它做了。你说得很有趣，因为当我与菲尔交谈时，他说，我认为格雷格对加拉格尔（Gallagher）有亲和力。这就是为什么你在我们的节目中看到这么多西瓜噱头的原因。这非常有趣。是的。喜剧演员加拉格尔。他说，
He used to smash watermelons. And if you were on the front row, you just get splattered. Yeah. I think that was it. Aaron told me, because after he spoke with you, he came to the DM. Oh, he found you. We DM. Oh, good.
他过去常砸西瓜。如果你在前排，你就会被溅到。是的。我想那就是它。亚伦告诉我，因为在他和你交谈后，他来到了私信。哦，他找到了你。我们私信。哦，太好了。
He said this cold open was the first thing they shot. And it was his first time on set for the office. And he kept laughing out loud. And Greg had to say to him, Aaron, this is not everybody loves Raymond. It's not a live show. You can't laugh out loud. And he was like, oh, no. Yes.
他说这个冷开场是他们拍摄的第一件事。这是他第一次在《办公室》片场。他一直大声笑。格雷格不得不对他说，亚伦，这不是《人人都爱雷蒙德》。这不是现场直播节目。你不能大声笑。他当时说，哦，不。是的。
he told me that it became a thing he became very self-conscious about because he'd only ever worked in four camera where they encourage you to laugh and laugh and laugh and then he had to start suppressing the laugh and suppressing the laugh and he said after a long day of work and suppressing the laugh he would go home and just burp constantly he told me that too he had given himself like some type of indigestion from holding in laughter all day oh well you guys this was very hard to watch without laughing for all of us. And if you go to one minute, 11 seconds, Phyllis had to put her head down because she was laughing so hard. The shot of the bullpen reacting. Yeah, was so funny to me. Well, there is a lot in this episode that we could not get through. Oh, man, the conference room.
他告诉我，这变成了一件他变得非常自我意识的事情，因为他只在四机位工作过，在那里他们鼓励你笑啊笑啊笑，然后他不得不开始抑制笑声，抑制笑声，他说在漫长的工作日后，抑制笑声，他会回家不停地打嗝。他也告诉了我那个。他因为整天憋着笑而给自己造成了某种消化不良。哦，好吧，伙计们，这对我们所有人来说都很难不笑。如果你去1分11秒，菲利斯不得不低下头，因为她笑得太厉害了。牛棚反应的镜头。是的，对我来说太搞笑了。嗯，这一集里有很多我们无法拍完的东西。哦，天哪，会议室。
We'll get there. I think we should get to the party planning committee now because they have been very busy decorating the conference room for the shower. Yeah. They have two bowls of M&Ms. So I talked to Aaron about this and I said, who came up with Astrid and Chevy? And he said Astrid was definitely Greg. He thought it'd be funny to see that name on an M&M. And then Chevy, he couldn't remember who came up with that. He said he thinks the room kind of pitched names. It's funny when I saw the bowls of M&Ms with the names, that was like a really popular thing. It might still be popular where you can get these personalized Eminems. Oh, I went to the website. It's still a whole thing. High school graduation, anniversaries, and I did this for my parents. My parents' anniversary. I got Eminems with their names on it.
我们会到的。我想我们现在应该去派对策划委员会了，因为他们一直在忙着装饰会议室准备洗礼派对。是的。他们有两碗M&M豆。所以我跟亚伦谈了这个，我说，谁想出了阿斯特丽德和Chevy？他说阿斯特丽德绝对是格雷格。他认为在M&M豆上看到那个名字会很有趣。然后Chevy，他不记得是谁想出来的了。他说他认为房间里的人大概投了名字。很有趣，当我看到写着名字的M&M豆碗时，那是一个非常受欢迎的东西。它可能仍然很受欢迎，你可以得到这些个性化的M&M豆。哦，我去了网站。它仍然是一整件事。高中毕业，周年纪念，我为我父母做了这个。我父母的周年纪念。我得到了写着他们名字的M&M豆。
Well, when we did the Jim and Pam wedding episode, Greg threw the cast of viewing party that was kind of like a little mini reception. And he had bowls of M&Ms that said Jim and Pam. He clearly was a big fan. He loved that you could personalize an M&M. I know. Well, they've gotten the name wrong, though. The party planning committee has Ashterd. Phyllis is like, that can't be right. Angela's like Michael wrote down Ashterd. And Michael said, yeah, it's like the name of a Viking princess.
嗯，当我们做吉姆和帕姆的婚礼那一集时，格雷格为剧组举办了一个观看派对，有点像一个小型的招待会。他有写着吉姆和帕姆的M&M豆碗。他显然是一个大粉丝。他喜欢你可以个性化M&M豆。我知道。嗯，他们把名字弄错了。派对策划委员会写了Ashterd。菲利斯说，那肯定不对。安吉拉说迈克尔写下了Ashterd。迈克尔说，是的，就像维京公主的名字。
So, of course, I had to research Astrid. I didn't research Astrid. And he is right. Michael is right. According to the internet, Astrid has Norse, Danish, and Swedish roots. It can mean godly strength or divine beauty, and the name Astrid has been used by Norway's royal family for hundreds of years. You know, Michael is annoyed by their effort. He says, Phyllis, we gave you a whole golden shower. I want my golden shower. He does. And then he
所以，当然，我不得不研究阿斯特丽德。我没有研究阿斯特丽德。他是对的。迈克尔是对的。根据互联网，阿斯特丽德有挪威、丹麦和瑞典的根源。它可以意味着神圣的力量或神圣的美丽，阿斯特丽德这个名字已经被挪威皇室使用了几百年。你知道，迈克尔对他们的努力感到恼火。他说，菲利斯，我们给了你一个完整的黄金洗礼（golden shower）。我想要我的黄金洗礼。他确实想要。然后他
has this talking head where he says he's going to love this baby, even if it isn't his, like that dog that nursed the tiger cub, right? Bazaar, but also beautiful, it happens. Jenna, I looked it up, and there are so many stories of dogs nursing tigers, but the one that caught my eye was on the Today Show in August of 2008. That's when we shot this episode. I know. And there was a safari park in Kansas with a white tiger named Sassy, who had cubs, but she was too sassy to nurse them. Okay. So a Golden Retriever stepped in, Isabella. Well, I would expect that from a golden retriever. I really would. What a good dog.
有这个谈话头，他说他会爱这个婴儿，即使它不是他的，就像那只喂养老虎幼崽的狗，对吧？离奇，但也美丽，它发生了。珍娜，我查了一下，有这么多狗喂养老虎的故事，但引起我注意的是2008年8月的《今日秀》（Today Show）。那是我们拍摄这一集的时候。我知道。堪萨斯州有一个野生动物园，有一只叫Sassy的白虎，它有幼崽，但她太傲慢（sassy）了，不肯喂养它们。好的。所以一只金毛猎犬介入了，伊莎贝拉（Isabella）。嗯，我会期待金毛猎犬那样做。我真的会。多好的一只狗。
Anyway, it just cracked me up that on the Today Show, there was a whole thing about Sassy and Isabella. And I think it ended up in our episode. Clearly, it did. Michael's going to bark orders at Phyllis. She's doing a talking head. I was supposed to be glaring at her in the background. And if you go to four minutes, 11 seconds, you can see me talking to Andy. And I'm so delighted that Phyllis is messing up.
总之，在《今日秀》上，关于Sassy和伊莎贝拉的整件事让我笑得前仰后合。我想它最终出现在我们的剧集里了。显然它确实出现了。迈克尔要对菲利斯大喊大叫。她正在做一个谈话头。我本应该在背景中怒视她。如果你去4分11秒，你可以看到我在和安迪（Andy）说话。我很高兴菲利斯搞砸了。
And then Michael walks in and kind of yells at her and says, make the party, make the party. And then he leaves and Phyllis starts pumping the balloon. Well, Steve improvised walking back in and saying, pump it, pump it. He did? He did. That was all improv. We just started cracking up. I thought I could see you starting to break in the background of that.
然后迈克尔走进来，有点对她大喊大叫，说，泵气，泵气。他做了吗？他做了。那全是即兴创作。我们刚开始笑得前仰后合。我以为我能看到你开始在背景中笑场。
Yeah. And Phyllis is starting to break, too. So now Jim is at his desk and Pam is trying to tell him this story. I loved this. It was so funny. When she's like, Sarah Chaya comes in, and he goes, oh, wait, Sarah Chaya comes in. And she's like, no, Sarah Kaya comes in. And then at the very end of the scene, when Dwight's like, who Sarah Kaya comes in, that was improvised.
是的。菲利斯也开始笑场了。所以现在吉姆在办公桌前，帕姆正试图告诉他这个故事。我喜欢这个。太搞笑了。当她说，萨拉·卡亚（Sarah Chaya）进来了，他说，哦，等等，萨拉·卡亚进来了。她说，不，萨拉·卡亚进来了。然后在场景的最后，当德怀特说，谁是萨拉·卡亚进来了，那是即兴创作的。
It was. Rain, Improvised that. That's not in the script. Oh, my gosh. I watched this and I feel like I have had these conversations. Yes. A hundred percent. And I love the line when she's like, why can't you just be in art school with me?
确实。雷恩，即兴创作了那个。那不在剧本里。哦，天哪。我看了这个，我觉得我经历过这些对话。是的，百分之百。我喜欢当她说，为什么你不能和我一起上艺术学校？
Because she's trying so hard to tell them this story. And, you know, this is the beginning of this storyline with Jim and Pam where we're going to show that this distance has gone on for a while. And maybe they're not connecting as easily as they used to. You know, long distance relationships are hard. And particularly when the people involved in your new life, the other person doesn't know. And it's kind of hard to keep track. Oh, yes. I mean, we experience this all the time when we go on locations.
因为她非常努力地想告诉他们这个故事。而且，你知道，这是吉姆和帕姆这条故事线的开始，我们将展示这种距离已经持续了一段时间。也许他们不像以前那样容易联系了。你知道，异地恋很难。特别是当你的新生活中的人，另一个人不知道时。而且很难跟踪。哦，是的。我的意思是，我们去外景地时经常经历这种情况。
Or I remember Lee went on location to shoot a movie and he was directing a film. And he's trying to tell me this hilarious story about some prop mishap that happened and everyone was laughing about these prop glasses. And I'm just like, I don't know who any of these people are. And what's really hard about it is that I like to be able to imagine the people or where they are. And we've talked about this when we get to a new place. We're like, send me a video of where you are so that when I'm talking to you, I know
或者我记得李（Lee）去外景地拍电影，他在导演一部电影。他试图告诉我一些关于发生的道具事故的搞笑故事，每个人都在笑这些道具眼镜。我只是想，我不知道这些人是谁。真正困难的是，我喜欢能够想象这些人或他们在哪里。我们谈过这个，当我们到达一个新地方时。我们就像，发给我一个你所在地方的视频，这样当我跟你说话时，我知道
what your little apartment looks like. or I know what your room looks like. Yeah, I have to have that. Otherwise, I'm a little unsettled because I can't picture where you are. Yes. So I feel like that's what Pam and Jim are up against right now. Yeah, he doesn't know her world. And it's some of that location situation kind of stuff.
你的小公寓看起来像什么。或者我知道你的房间看起来像什么。是的，我必须有那个。否则，我有点不安，因为我无法想象你在哪里。是的。所以我感觉这就是帕姆和吉姆现在面临的情况。是的，他不知道她的世界。这有点像那种外景地的情况。
I love the next scene. I love it so much. Angela is preparing this poster board full of baby photos because they're going to play a game where you have to guess which baby. photo belongs to which employee, and Andy comes in, and he mistakes Phyllis' baby photo for Angela. Mm-hmm. Will you please tell me about shooting this scene, Angela?
我喜欢下一个场景。我非常喜欢它。安吉拉正在准备这个贴满婴儿照片的海报板，因为他们要玩一个游戏，你必须猜哪张婴儿照片属于哪个员工，安迪进来了，他把菲利斯的婴儿照片误认为是安吉拉的。嗯。请告诉我关于拍摄这个场景的事，安吉拉？
Well, one of the reasons I storm off is because I started to laugh. I could tell. That was me trying to get out of there before you saw me laughing on camera. So here's the thing. Greg directed this episode, right? And he said, you guys, can you bring in your actual baby photos? And he said, if you don't have a baby photo, it could be like when you're a toddler. Just can I get photos of you guys when you were little?
嗯，我冲出去的原因之一是因为我开始笑了。我看得出来。那是我试图在你看到我在镜头前笑之前离开那里。所以事情是这样的。格雷格导演了这一集，对吧？他说，伙计们，你们能带上你们真实的婴儿照片吗？他说，如果你没有婴儿照片，它可以是像你蹒跚学步时那样。只要能给我你们小时候的照片就行吗？
And we did, right? Yes, we got a lot of fan mail about that. Were these actual photos of the cast? They were. Yeah. There's three people who aren't on the poster. Me? Yep.
我们做了，对吧？是的，我们收到了很多关于那个的粉丝邮件。这些是剧组的真实照片吗？它们是。是的。有三个人不在海报上。我？是的。
John and Steve. Everyone else is an actual baby photo from their childhood. Including Amy Ryan. She's up there. Yes. And so was Mindy? I mean, we're all on the board. We're all on the board.
约翰（John）和史蒂夫。其他人都是他们童年的真实婴儿照片。包括艾米·瑞安（Amy Ryan）。她在上面。是的。明迪（Mindy）也是？我的意思是，我们都在板子上。我们都在板子上。
Jenna, what did I bring in today? Do you want to share with them? You brought in. your baby photo, the one that was on the board with your little hand up on your little chubby cheek. I know. I know. You guys, it's really me. I get asked this all the time. And my mom, I called my mom, and I said, Mom, we're doing the baby shower episode and it's my baby photo. And I want to know everything about it. She said, oh, I have several more of that same day where we put you in different poses. Oh, so there's more. But here's what my mom said. She took me to J.C. Pinnies at the Acadiana
Jenna，我今天带了什么来？你想和大家分享一下吗？你带了……你的婴儿照，就是那张贴在板子上，你那只小手放在胖乎乎的小脸蛋上的照片。我知道，我知道。伙计们，那真的是我。我经常被问到这个问题。我给我妈打了电话，我说，妈，我们要录婴儿洗礼那一集，那是我的婴儿照。我想知道关于它的一切。她说，哦，那天我还拍了好几张，我们让你摆了不同的姿势。哦，所以还有更多。但我妈是这么说的，她带我去了路易斯安那州拉斐特的阿卡迪亚纳购物中心。
shopping mall in Lafayette, Louisiana. I was around six months old. And apparently, I was born with just a ton of hair. And it was sort of an Auburn Brown. She said I had so much hair, just right out of the gate. I had tons of hair. And so she tried to style it for the photo. I was like, Mom, you gave me like a Mohawk with bangs. So yeah, she said she had tried to put a little ribbon at the top. That would have made more sense. Right. But it, I don't know, it fell out or something. And then. And they propped me up on my hand like that. It's so funny because I remember those photo studio photo shoots. That was a thing of my childhood as well.
我当时大约六个月大。显然，我出生时就有一头浓密的头发。那是种红棕色。她说我刚出生时头发就特别多。真的，头发多得惊人。所以她试着给它做个造型。我当时就想，妈，你给我弄了个带刘海的莫霍克发型。所以是的，她说她试着在头顶系个小丝带。那样可能更合理。对吧。但不知道怎么回事，它掉了还是怎么的。然后，他们就这样把我的手撑起来。这太搞笑了，因为我记得那些照相馆的拍摄。那也是我童年的一部分。
And they would have these carpeted blocks. Yes. And you would like be propped up on a little carpeted block. I'm propped up because I can't sit yet. Yes. Yes. Anyway, there you go. That's my actual baby photo, you guys.
他们会有那种铺着地毯的方块。是的。你会像这样被撑在一个铺着地毯的小方块上。我被撑着是因为我还不会坐。是的，是的。总之，就是这样。伙计们，那就是我真正的婴儿照。
Well, since mine wasn't on the board, I tell you what, I'll post mine on the office ladies' pods. so you can see me as a baby too. Yes, and I'll ask my mom if she can find any other photos from that particular photo shoot. Please. As Michael is preparing for Jan's arrival, he needs to tell Holly that he's going to be kind of cold to her today because he needs to protect Jan's feelings. Jan's bloated feelings. Yeah, because Jan is going to come in, she's going to be so unattractive.
好吧，既然我的没在板子上，我告诉你，我会把我的照片发在《办公室女士》的播客上，这样你们也能看到我小时候的样子。好的，我会问我妈能不能找到那次拍摄的其他照片。拜托了。迈克尔在为简的到来做准备时，他需要告诉霍莉，他今天会对她冷淡一点，因为他需要保护简的感受。简那膨胀的感受。是的，因为简要来了，她会显得非常没有吸引力。
And Holly is very attractive. And yeah, he just wants to. to be sensitive. So he warns her. But then Jan arrives. She's not pregnant. She has a baby. And she looks amazing. Yeah. But she's had the baby. We had a fan question from Brittany Y, Sarah M, and many more. Who is the baby that played Astrid? I will tell you, thanks to Jamesopedia. First of all, you know, babies are played by many babies. Mm-hmm. Sometimes, there are a set of twins, like in the case of Cece. Cece was this set of twins, and it was the same twin girls all through the show.
而霍莉非常有吸引力。是的，他只是想……保持敏感。所以他提醒了她。但随后简到了。她没有怀孕。她生了个孩子。而且她看起来棒极了。是的，但她已经生了。我们收到了来自布列塔尼·Y、莎拉·M和许多其他人的粉丝提问。谁是扮演阿斯特丽德的婴儿？多亏了《詹姆斯百科》，我会告诉你们。首先，你们知道，婴儿是由许多婴儿扮演的。嗯。有时，会有双胞胎，就像西西的情况一样。西西就是那对双胞胎，整个剧集里都是那两个双胞胎女孩。
They were absolute sweethearts, and I loved them. But sometimes, especially with a baby this little, it's like three babies, five babies, lots of babies. Oh, Philip was several different babies and then a different toddler. Yes. So this is because there are rules about babies working on a set. They can only work for like 20 minutes. And I think that's a good thing. Yes.
她们绝对是小甜心，我爱死她们了。但有时，特别是对于这么小的婴儿，可能需要三个、五个，甚至很多个婴儿。哦，菲利普就是由好几个不同的婴儿扮演的，后来又换成了不同的幼儿。是的。这是因为片场对婴儿工作有规定。他们一次只能工作大约20分钟。我觉得这是件好事。是的。
Also, if you have a baby and one of them's fussy, you can swap them out for a different baby. They're all dressed the same. You go backstage and there's like six babies in the same outfit. So Astrid was played first by a set of twins and another baby. Here's the crazy thing. The twins' names were Matthew and Joey Levinson. Crazy. Right?
另外，如果你有一个婴儿，其中一个闹脾气，你可以换另一个婴儿。他们都穿得一模一样。你走到后台，会有六个穿着同样衣服的婴儿。所以阿斯特丽德最初是由一对双胞胎和另一个婴儿扮演的。最疯狂的是，双胞胎的名字叫马修和乔伊·莱文森。太疯狂了，对吧？
And they were playing Jan Levinson's baby. Yes. The other baby was Harvey Gris. So her babies were the Levinson green babies. Okay. All right. And then that was on one day. The other day, we had a set of triplets playing Astrid.
他们竟然在扮演简·莱文森的孩子。是的。另一个婴儿是哈维·格里斯。所以她的孩子是莱文森-格里斯宝宝。好吧。好的，那是第一天。第二天，我们有一组三胞胎扮演阿斯特丽德。
They were Chase, Chloe, and Juliette Purcell. So those are all the babies. We also had a fake baby. We did have a fake baby, yeah. And it's really funny because if you look at the call sheet, scene by scene, it'll say real baby or fake baby, like what we're using in the scene. would stagger them, right? Because the babies could only work for 20 minutes. So you'd have a scene with a real baby and then a scene with fake baby. Well, Michael walks out of the kitchen and he sees Jan with the baby. I can't imagine how he felt. He'd been to all of his birthing classes with her.
他们是蔡斯、克洛伊和朱丽叶·珀塞尔。这就是所有的婴儿。我们还有一个假婴儿。我们确实有一个假婴儿，是的。这很有趣，因为如果你看通告单，每一场戏都会写着真婴儿还是假婴儿，看我们在那场戏里用的是什么。我们会错开他们，对吧？因为婴儿只能工作20分钟。所以你会有一场戏用真婴儿，然后一场戏用假婴儿。迈克尔从厨房走出来，看到简抱着孩子。我无法想象他的感受。他曾和她一起参加了所有的分娩课程。
And then he was sort of left out of this big moment. And he confronts Jan about it. This is one of my favorite couplets of dialogue from the whole episode. Okay. It's so rich. Michael says, why didn't you call me? I could have helped. Jan said, well, the birth instructor thought it wasn't a good idea for you to be there. So Michael says, oh man, him, that guy, he had no sense of humor. And I proved him wrong in so many ways. And it just made me think about these classes. I wish we could have seen Michael trying to do comedy bits with like a birthing instructor. I would have loved to see that scene. I think what Jan has done to Michael is so cruel. I know that she didn't call him.
然后他被排除在这个重大时刻之外了。他为此质问简。这是整集中我最喜欢的对话对联之一。好的。太丰富了。迈克尔说，你为什么不叫我？我本可以帮忙的。简说，分娩指导员认为你在场不是个好主意。所以迈克尔说，哦天哪，那家伙，他一点幽默感都没有。我用很多方式证明了他错了。这让我想到这些课程。我真希望我们能看到迈克尔试图和分娩指导员一起表演喜剧片段。我真的很想看那场戏。我觉得简对迈克尔所做的一切太残忍了。我知道她没叫他。
And also in that scene, Jan is like, Michael, you don't know what I have been through. And he said, no, no, I don't. And I love Steve's delivery on that. I know. I guess she feels bad and she lets him hold the baby, but it says the baby has to stay in the car seat. And then Michael has this very sweet talking head where he says he loves babies and he tries to pick them up and hold one every day. It just nourishes him. And then we see this really sweet montage of Michael and his.
在那场戏里，简说，迈克尔，你不知道我经历了什么。他说，不，不，我不知道。我喜欢史蒂夫对那句台词的处理。我知道。我想她感到内疚，就让他抱了抱孩子，但她说孩子必须待在汽车安全座椅里。然后迈克尔有一个非常甜蜜的独白，他说他喜欢婴儿，每天都试着抱抱他们。这让他感到滋养。然后我们看到了迈克尔和他的……
babies and the babies love him. They really do. Well, that's because it's Steve Correll is holding the babies. I know. I know. Not to say that they wouldn't have loved Michael, but Steve is a natural with kids. I know. We had a fan question from Evan L. and Stacey M. in the scenes where Michael is holding all the babies, were those hired actors? Or did the crew just go out and let people line up to have their baby held by Steve Correll? All of those babies were the children of our writers, and our crew. So here is a list of the babies. At nine minutes, you have baby on the street. This is Emma Holland, daughter of our editor, Dean Holland, and that is also Dean's wife, Tasha. At nine minutes, nine seconds, I'm calling this one baby at the bathroom. That baby is Theodore Grandi, the woman is
婴儿们在一起的甜蜜蒙太奇，婴儿们都很喜欢他。他们确实很喜欢。好吧，那是因为是史蒂夫·卡瑞尔在抱着婴儿。我知道，我知道。并不是说他们不会喜欢迈克尔，但史蒂夫天生就擅长和孩子相处。我知道。我们收到了埃文·L和斯泰西·M的粉丝提问。在迈克尔抱着所有婴儿的场景中，那些是雇来的演员吗？还是剧组只是出去让人们排队让史蒂夫·卡瑞尔抱他们的孩子？所有那些婴儿都是我们编剧和剧组的孩子。这是婴儿名单。在9分钟时，那个街上的婴儿是我们的剪辑师迪恩·霍兰德的女儿艾玛，那个女人也是迪恩的妻子塔莎。在9分9秒，我称这个为浴室里的婴儿。那个婴儿是西奥多·格兰迪，那个女人是……
Sage Grandi, and this is the son of our writer Charlie Grandi. At nine minutes to 15 seconds, we have double baby. And that is our writer Mike Scher's wife, J.J. Philbin, and their baby William, along with our camera operator Matt Sone's wife, Melissa, and their baby Devin. And the final baby at 9 minutes, 17 seconds, that is Avery Farrell, the daughter of our writer Anthony Farrell. The woman was a background performer, but that's Anthony loading the stroller into the car. So we had had kind of like a little mini baby boom on our set. All of these kids were around the same age. I texted with Dean. He said his daughter, Emma, is now 13 years old. And she tells everybody that she's one of the babies on the office. And Angela, I know you get asked a lot about Isabel because she was right around the same age, too.
塞奇·格兰迪，这是我们编剧查理·格兰迪的儿子。在9分15秒，我们有双胞胎宝宝。那是我们编剧迈克·谢尔的妻子J.J.菲尔宾和他们的孩子威廉，以及我们的摄影师马特·索恩的妻子梅丽莎和他们的孩子德文。最后一个在9分17秒的婴儿是艾弗里·法瑞尔，是我们编剧安东尼·法瑞尔的女儿。那个女人是背景演员，但那是安东尼在把婴儿车装进车里。所以我们的片场经历了一场小小的婴儿潮。所有这些孩子年龄都差不多。我给迪恩发了短信。他说他的女儿艾玛现在13岁了。她告诉所有人她是《办公室》里的婴儿之一。安吉拉，我知道你经常被问到伊莎贝尔，因为她当时也差不多大。
Yes, Isabel just had her 13th birthday. There was this baby boom. And it was really fun for us to have our babies on set. And I get asked if she was in this episode and she wasn't. And you know why? The day they filmed the scene with all the babies was my day off. Oh. And I wanted to be home with my baby, not bringing my baby to work. So I wasn't in it. And they said, don't worry, Angela, we're going to get Isabel in there. And they did. She ended up having a very fun day on set years later at C.C's dance recital. I can't wait. I know. Well, Michael's going to try to make the best of it. Okay. He is going to present Astrid to the office. office and they're going to go into the conference room. Jenna, he does the Lion King and holds the car seat over his head. I know. I hope that was fake baby day. That was fake baby and that was all scripted.
是的，伊莎贝尔刚过了13岁生日。当时确实有婴儿潮。我们的婴儿在片场对我们来说真的很有趣。我经常被问到她是否出演了这一集，她没有。你知道为什么吗？他们拍摄所有婴儿场景的那天是我休息的日子。哦。我想和我的孩子待在家里，而不是带她去上班。所以我没参与。他们说，别担心，安吉拉，我们会让伊莎贝尔出镜的。他们确实做到了。多年后，她在西西的舞蹈独奏会上度过了非常愉快的一天。我等不及了。我知道。好吧，迈克尔会试着充分利用这一点。好的。他要向办公室介绍阿斯特丽德。他们要进会议室。詹娜，他模仿了《狮子王》，把汽车安全座椅举过头顶。我知道。我希望那是假婴儿日。那是假婴儿，而且全是照剧本演的。
Oh, boy. Well, when we move into the conference room, Kevin is like, you know, the fact that the babies here kind of ruins the games. And Michael is like, no, it doesn't. No, it doesn't. It kind of did. Well, you know, the theme is a baby shower in all. all the games are for an expecting mother. So it was really awkward. But there are a lot of scenes
哦，天哪。好吧，当我们进入会议室时，凯文说，你知道，婴儿在这里有点破坏游戏气氛。迈克尔说，不，并没有。不，并没有。确实有点破坏了。好吧，你知道，主题是婴儿洗礼，所有的游戏都是为准妈妈准备的。所以真的很尴尬。但在这个会议室婴儿洗礼中，有很多场景……
in this conference room baby shower that didn't make it. I'm going to share a few. The first one is, Jenna, one of the funniest things I have had to witness and we could not get through it. Kevin thinks he might be the sperm donor. And the look on Jan's face is amazing. Sam, can you play that from the deleted scenes? Hey, Jan, you went to a sperm bank? Yes, I did. I donated sporm. sperm. Oh. Maybe I'm the father. Well, this is a highly exclusive establishment. Next to the IHOP?
没能放进去。我要分享几个。第一个是，詹娜，我见过的最有趣的事情之一，我们当时根本无法演下去。凯文认为他可能是精子捐赠者。简脸上的表情太棒了。萨姆，你能播放一下删减片段吗？嘿，简，你去过精子库？是的，我去过。我捐了精子。哦。也许我是父亲。好吧，这是一个高度排他的机构。在IHOP隔壁？
Well, I paid for an ideal specimen. Are you saying Kevin is not an ideal specimen? This is a wonderful shower, everyone. Thank you. I might have done it with Chad. It's not Kevin. We could not get through it. Whenever Brian said, you mean the one by I. hop just every single time because Malora's reaction is Jan was so good. And then, you know,
好吧，我付钱买了一个理想的样本。你是说凯文不是理想样本？这是一个很棒的洗礼，大家。谢谢。我可能和查德做过。不是凯文。我们根本无法演下去。每当布莱恩说，“你是说IHOP旁边那家吗”，每次都这样，因为梅洛拉作为简的反应太好了。然后，你知道……
she says she paid for premium sperm, which we learned might have been antirotics. I love there are so many deleted scenes about who the father of Jan's baby is. We've got Andy Rodic, maybe Kevin. There's a lot of speculation that it's Hunter. Yes. And none of these scenes actually. actually made it into the episodes. So what do you think about that? Do you think like if something didn't make it in, it counts? Or does it not count if it doesn't make it in the episode? So yeah, what is the canon, right? Yes, exactly. Well, I guess it would have to be what aired, right? So then that would mean it's just a mystery. It's a mystery. She paid top dollar for it, though. That's what we know. Yeah, that's all we know and all will ever truly
她说她付钱买了优质精子，我们后来得知那可能是安迪·罗迪克。我喜欢关于谁是简孩子父亲的删减片段。我们有安迪·罗迪克，也许是凯文。有很多猜测说是亨特。是的。这些场景实际上都没有进入正片。你们对此怎么看？你认为如果某样东西没放进去，它还算数吗？还是说如果没进正片就不算数了？所以，什么是正史，对吧？是的，完全正确。好吧，我想那必须是播出的内容，对吧？所以那意味着这只是个谜。是个谜。不过她确实付了大价钱。这就是我们所知道的。是的，这就是我们所知道的，也是我们永远会……
know. And I think the one thing we also know is that it's not Michael's because he had to wear two condoms. We know that. Yeah. We know whose baby it's not. That's right. I got this cool letter from Kristen B. She has a background catch and she said, the first time I watched this episode after having my son, I almost jumped out of my seat when I saw the pink donut pillow on Jan's chair at the baby shower. I had never noticed it prior to giving birth. But after I got one at the hospital, myself, I just have to say this is amazing and 10-10 for attention to detail. That is a great background catch. I noticed it as well. I loved that detail. I did too. I don't know if you guys also noticed behind Jan's chair, there's a little table, and on the table is a big bird stuffed animal.
知道的全部。我想我们还知道的一件事是，那不是迈克尔的，因为他不得不戴两个避孕套。我们知道这一点。是的。我们知道是谁的孩子不是。没错。我收到了克里斯汀·B的一封很酷的信。她有一个背景发现，她说，我在生完儿子后第一次看这一集时，看到婴儿洗礼上简椅子上的粉色甜甜圈坐垫，我差点从座位上跳起来。我在生孩子之前从未注意到它。但在我自己从医院拿到一个后，我不得不说这太棒了，细节处理满分。那是一个很棒的背景发现。我也注意到了。我喜欢那个细节。我也喜欢。我不知道你们是否也注意到了简椅子后面有一张小桌子，桌子上有一个大鸟毛绒玩具。
There is a deleted scene where Michael tells Phyllis he wants storks. She said she couldn't get storks, and he's like, look, I barely got Jan to even come today. This needs to be a big party. If you can't get a stork, I at least want big bird. And the best Phyllis could do is she got a big bird stuffed animal. Wow. Yeah. Oh, that is so great. Well, the group gives Jan her gift.
有一个删减场景，迈克尔告诉菲利斯他想要鹳鸟。她说她弄不到鹳鸟，他说，听着，我好不容易才让简今天来。这必须是个盛大的派对。如果你弄不到鹳鸟，我至少想要大鸟。菲利斯能做的最好的就是弄到了一个大鸟毛绒玩具。哇。是的。哦，那太棒了。好吧，大家给了简礼物。
It's a stroller. I think this is a very nice gift. It's a very nice gift because it's a big ticket item, but she's already got a stroller. She has an orbit. That Oscar tells us costs $1,200. Yeah. Hmm. Dwight is curious. He's like, I need to see how good this stroller really is. Yeah, he said his whole bomb shelter, bunker thing that he built didn't even cost that much. And he needs to see what the stroller's made of if it's going to cost that much. So, yeah, he wheels the stroller out and then Jan is going to sing to the baby. Oh, Jenna. How did you get through this? How did you get through it? It was like bite the inside of your cheek. Don't make eye contact with anyone. And also at the same time, in total awe of Malora.
是一辆婴儿车。我觉得这是一个非常好的礼物。这是一个非常好的礼物，因为它是个大件商品，但她已经有一辆婴儿车了。她有一辆奥比特。奥斯卡告诉我们价值1200美元。是的。嗯。德怀特很好奇。他说，我需要看看这辆婴儿车到底有多好。是的，他说他建造的整个防空洞、地堡之类的东西都没花那么多钱。如果它值那么多钱，他需要看看这辆婴儿车是用什么做的。所以，是的，他把婴儿车推了出来，然后简要给孩子唱歌。哦，詹娜。你是怎么熬过来的？你是怎么熬过来的？就像咬住脸颊内侧。不要和任何人有眼神接触。同时，也对梅洛拉感到无比敬佩。
Yes. Who has an amazing singing voice and performs as a singer, guys. Yes. She has albums. Yes. She's an amazing singer. She just owned this moment so wholeheartedly. There is a scene, Jenna, that was in the script that we shot. I remember shooting it because the timing and everything in it was amazing. amazing. So Jan is singing son of a preacher man. She's belting it out. And Ryan comes in urgently to tell her something. She won't stop singing. And I printed out the script. Here, Jenna. Just read right here. Okay. So I'm going to be Ryan. Yeah. Okay. And you guys forgive my singing. I'm not a singer. Okay. Was a son of a preacher man. Yes, he was. Hey, Jan. He was. Jan. Yes, he was. You parked in the handicapped spot. Keys are in my purse. I'll just, I'll take them. Did I do good? You did great. Sorry to make you guys suffer through my singing. Malora was amazing. She never missed a beat. She sang where her keys were.
是的。她有一副美妙的歌喉，而且本身就是一位歌手，伙计们。是的。她有专辑。是的。她是一位了不起的歌手。她全心全意地掌控了这一刻。詹娜，剧本里有一个我们拍过的场景。我记得拍摄它是因为它的节奏和一切都太棒了。所以简在唱《传教士之子》。她在大声歌唱。瑞安急忙进来告诉她一些事。她不停下来。我打印了剧本。给你，詹娜。就读这里。好的。所以我要演瑞安。好的。你们原谅我的歌声。我不是歌手。好的。《传教士之子》。是的，他是。嘿，简。他是。简。是的，他是。你停在残疾人车位了。钥匙在我的包里。我……我会拿走的。我演得好吗？你演得太棒了。抱歉让你们忍受我的歌声。梅洛拉太棒了。她从没错过节拍。她唱着她的钥匙在哪里。
It was amazing. I did a mini deep dive on son of a preacher man. Did you really? Yes. I think we should take a break. And when we come back, I'll tell you what I found. Okay. All right.
太棒了。我深入研究了一下《传教士之子》。你真的研究了？是的。我想我们应该休息一下。等我们回来，我会告诉你们我发现了什么。好的。好的。
We are back. And I'm going to start us off with a fan question from Yvette M and Alexandra S. Why was the song Son of a Preacher Man chosen for Jan to sing to her baby? I asked Erin who picked this song and Aaron said he isn't sure if Mindy picked it per se but she was pushing it. He said I don't remember how exactly it came up in the writer's room but the minute it was out there Mindy was like that's got to be it. That has got to be it. So I think we have Mindy to thank for that. I got curious about the song so I did a little deep dive on it. Son of a preacher man was written by John Hurley and Ronnie Wilkins. It was recorded by Dusty Springfield in 1968,
我们回来了。我要从伊薇特·M和亚历山德拉·S的粉丝提问开始。为什么选择《传教士之子》这首歌让简唱给她的孩子听？我问了亚伦是谁选的这首歌，亚伦说他不确定是不是明迪选的，但她确实在推动。他说我不记得在编剧室里它是怎么提出来的，但一旦提出来，明迪就说，就是这首了。那一定是这首。所以我认为我们得感谢明迪。我对这首歌很好奇，所以我深入研究了一下。《传教士之子》是由约翰·赫利和罗尼·威尔金斯创作的。它由达斯蒂·斯普林菲尔德在1968年录制，
and her version is most popular. It's been covered many times by many artists. Here's what I found interesting. Apparently, the rights to record the song were originally offered to Aretha Franklin. She was the daughter of a preacher, and the rumor is that she turned it down because she worried that maybe it might be a little disrespectful. But she changed her mind. No. And she recorded a cover version of the song just one year later in 1969 for her album Soul Sister. I had to hear it.
她的版本最受欢迎。它被许多艺术家翻唱过很多次。我觉得有趣的是，显然，录制这首歌的版权最初是提供给艾瑞莎·富兰克林的。她是传教士的女儿，传闻说她拒绝了，因为她担心这可能有点不敬。但她改变了主意。不。她在一年后的1969年为她的专辑《灵魂姐妹》录制了一个翻唱版本。我必须听听。
Sam, will you play it? It's so good, isn't it? She always gives me chills. Dolly Parton also did a cover in 1996 for her album, Treasures, and it is also a gem. Do you want to hear that one? Yes. Billy Ray was a preacher's son when his daddy would be it. When they'd gather around started talking, that's when Billy would take me to walk in.
萨姆，你能播放一下吗？太好听了，不是吗？她总是让我起鸡皮疙瘩。多莉·帕顿也在1996年为她的专辑《珍宝》做了一个翻唱，那也是一颗宝石。你想听那个吗？是的。比利·雷是个传教士的儿子，当他爸爸……当他们聚在一起开始谈话时，那就是比利带我去散步的时候。
Through the backyard, we go walking. I mean... I can listen to these women sing anything. They're legends. Legends in our podcast today. Do we need to hear Dusties? I think we need to hear Dusties. I mean, we have to hear Dusties.
穿过后院，我们去散步。我是说……我可以听这些女性唱任何歌。她们是传奇。我们今天播客里的传奇。我们需要听达斯蒂的吗？我想我们需要听达斯蒂的。我是说，我们必须听达斯蒂的。
It's son of a preacher man day today. I mean, I just want to hear all of them. I feel so embarrassed that I even attempted to sing it at all to recreate the scene with Ryan. I am so sorry. Billy Ray was the preacher's son. And when his daddy would visit, he'd come along. When they gather around his daughter talking, that some Billy would take me a walk in.
今天是《传教士之子》日。我是说，我只想听所有的版本。我对自己试图唱它来重现与瑞安的场景感到非常尴尬。真的很抱歉。比利·雷是传教士的儿子。当他爸爸来访时，他会跟着。当他们聚在一起谈话时，比利会带我去散步。
I through the backyard we go walking. Then he look into my eyes. Lord knows to my surprise. The only one who could ever reach me was a son of a preacher man. The only voice. Oh, so good. All right, all right. Here's what I have to say.
穿过后院，我们去散步。然后他看着我的眼睛。上帝知道，令我惊讶的是。唯一能触动我的人就是传教士之子。唯一的声音。哦，太棒了。好吧，好吧。这是我要说的。
Kudos to John Hurley and Ronnie Wilkins. Because when you write a song that can be sung by all of these different people with their different spins on it and their different arrangement. And it still knocks your song. socks off every time. You have written a good song. Yep. One last thing I want to say about son of a preacher man is that when Malora sang it, she improvised the snapping. And you know what? It about got me on the floor. We were so trying to suppress laughter that one more thing was like the tipping point, you know? Yes. And so as she's swaying and singing, when she just starts doing that
向约翰·赫利和罗尼·威尔金斯致敬。因为当你写出一首可以被所有这些不同的人用他们不同的风格和编曲演唱的歌时。而且它每次都能让你惊艳。你写了一首好歌。是的。关于《传教士之子》我想说的最后一件事是，当梅洛拉唱它时，她即兴加入了响指。你知道吗？这差点让我笑倒在地。我们当时极力忍住笑，那多出来的一下简直是压死骆驼的最后一根稻草，你知道吗？是的。所以当她摇摆着唱歌时，当她开始那样做……
snap, I was like, oh, Lord, I'm not going to make it. I am not going to make it. there are really great scripted talking heads of people reacting to it. And Stanley had a great one where he was like, I used to like that song. Well, Jim is going to try to describe it to Pam. She's at the laundromat and she can't hear anything he's saying. Why couldn't she just walk away from the machines, Jenna? You know what? Megan P. would like to know the answer to that question as well.
打响指，我当时想，哦，天哪，我撑不住了。我撑不住了。有一些非常棒的剧本独白是人们对此的反应。斯坦利有一个很棒的独白，他说，我以前喜欢那首歌。好吧，吉姆要试着向帕姆描述它。她在自助洗衣店，什么都听不见。詹娜，她为什么不能直接走开那些机器呢？你知道吗？梅根·P也想知道那个问题的答案。
Megan, it's the first thing I thought. She hasn't talked to him all day. She finally has free time. walk away from the machine. I'll tell you two things. Number one, right before this phone call, there was a bit of the scene that got clipped. Pam is with her friend at the laundromat, and they are together and they're talking about a class assignment, and she says, oh, just one second, I'm going to take this call. So maybe she felt like she couldn't walk away. But also in the script, there is a version where she does walk away from the machines, and the problem is not.
梅根，这是我第一时间想到的。她一整天都没和他说话。她终于有空闲时间了。走开那些机器吧。我告诉你们两件事。第一，在这个电话之前，有一段场景被剪掉了。帕姆和她的朋友在洗衣店，她们在一起谈论课程作业，她说，哦，等一下，我要接个电话。所以也许她觉得她不能走开。但在剧本里，有一个版本是她确实走开了，问题不在于……
not that the machines are loud. The problem is simply that Pam is not understanding what's so bad about Jan singing to her baby. So it's another kind of like miscommunication. Like you had to be there kind of things. But they kept the loud laundry machine version in. I'll have you know, location alert. The laundromat was Launderman on Sherman Way in North Hollywood, California. I like to throw these out there because there are these office tours where, people go around and look at our locations. And so I thought, I don't know if you want to see where Pam did her laundry. That's where. Okay. So Pam has this talking head at the laundromat where she says that she's not frustrated. You know, they have these kind of days where they don't connect,
机器很吵。问题仅仅是帕姆不明白简给孩子唱歌有什么不好的。所以这是另一种沟通不畅。就像那种“你得在现场”的感觉。但他们保留了洗衣机很吵的版本。我得告诉你们，地点警报。洗衣店是加利福尼亚州北好莱坞谢尔曼大道上的Launderman。我喜欢把这些抛出来，因为有这些《办公室》之旅，人们会四处走动看看我们的拍摄地点。所以我以为，我不知道你们是否想看看帕姆在哪里洗衣服。就是那里。好的。所以帕姆在洗衣店有一个独白，她说她并不沮丧。你知道，他们会有这种无法连接的日子，
even when they're together in Scranton. And then she discovers that she washed her lipstick and it got all over her green towel. You know, I recently washed Lee's wallet and car key. I remember this. You called me and you're like, I washed the, keys to the car, his whole entire wallet. Whole wallet. Whole wallet. And now he couldn't find his wallet for days. He was like, where is my wallet?
即使他们都在斯克兰顿。然后她发现她洗了口红，弄得她绿色的毛巾上到处都是。你知道，我最近洗了李的钱包和车钥匙。我记得这个。你给我打电话说，我洗了车钥匙，他整个钱包。整个钱包。整个钱包。现在他好几天找不到钱包了。他当时说，我的钱包在哪？
I can't find my wallet. It was in his pocket. Yeah. In the laundry basket. And I didn't check the pockets. I threw in the laundry. I found it in the dryer. It went through a full wash cycle, a full dryer cycle.
我找不到我的钱包。它在他的口袋里。是的。在洗衣篮里。我没检查口袋。我直接扔进了洗衣机。我在烘干机里找到了它。它经过了完整的洗涤周期，完整的烘干周期。
I said, babe, I found your wallet. Wait, did the credit cards? Did it all get melted? Did he have to get everything new? Lady, he went out, he bought some gas, and the credit cards worked. Well, how about that? So, I guess you didn't have it. You didn't have it on high heat. No, I did dry on low. And the car key still works, because it's one of those little like, bur-b-b-b-b-c-y. Yeah, it still works.
我说，宝贝，我找到你的钱包了。等等，信用卡呢？都融化了吗？他必须重新办所有东西吗？女士，他出去加了点油，信用卡还能用。好吧，那怎么样？所以，我想你没用高温。不，我用低温烘干的。车钥匙还能用，因为它是那种小小的……是的，它还能用。
While all of the singing is going on, Dwight decides he's going to put the stroller to the ultimate test. Yes, we had a fan question from Beth E. Rachel R., Amy F. and Julie G., how many of those strollers did you use for the scenes where Dwight tests its durability? This is why I was on the phone with Phil Shea for an hour yesterday. Well, how many did they use? I'll tell you, it started with Phil Shea doing a ton of research to find the perfect stroller for this episode. He said he and Greg had a long talk about how Gian was the kind of person who, would have to have the fanciest stroller.
当所有的歌声都在进行时，德怀特决定他要对婴儿车进行终极测试。是的，我们收到了贝丝·E、瑞秋·R、艾米·F和朱莉·G的粉丝提问，在德怀特测试其耐用性的场景中，你们用了多少辆婴儿车？这就是我昨天和菲尔·谢通了一个小时电话的原因。好吧，他们用了多少辆？我告诉你们，这始于菲尔·谢做了大量的研究来寻找这一集完美的婴儿车。他说他和格雷格长谈过简是那种……
In the script, it's written that the stroller is indestructible, and he wanted to find something that would even look out of place in Scranton. So he went on a search for an indestructible luxury stroller, and he found out about the Orbit Baby Stroller, which was kind of a startup stroller at the time. It launched in September of 2006, so just two years before this episode, It was invented by two dads, Brian White and Joseph High. I think it's high.
必须拥有最豪华婴儿车的人。在剧本里，写着婴儿车是坚不可摧的，他想找一些在斯克兰顿看起来格格不入的东西。所以他开始寻找坚不可摧的豪华婴儿车，他发现了Orbit婴儿车，这在当时算是一个初创婴儿车。它于2006年9月推出，就在这一集两年前。它是由两位父亲布莱恩·怀特和约瑟夫·海发明的。我想是海。
Joseph, I'm sorry if I got that wrong. And they made it because Brian had just become a dad. And he said that his back really hurt whenever he was trying to get the baby in and out of the car seat and the car. So in his garage, they made a wooden prototype. They studied all kinds of things. But they also sought to use green materials. I like these fellas. Yeah, and this car seat was cool because Phil said it looked kind of weird, but it also rotates 360 degrees.
约瑟夫，如果我弄错了很抱歉。他们制造它是为了布莱恩刚当上爸爸。他说每当他试图把孩子放进或抱出汽车安全座椅和汽车时，他的背就很痛。所以在他的车库里，他们做了一个木制原型。他们研究了各种各样的东西。但他们也寻求使用绿色材料。我喜欢这些家伙。是的，这个汽车安全座椅很酷，因为菲尔说它看起来有点奇怪，但它也可以360度旋转。
So Phil was like, it was so cool. Like if you want to get your baby out of the car and not remove the car seat, you can swivel it, and then you can get your baby out of the car really easy. Well, Jenna, you know, Phil Shea had a few extra orbits left over, and I was a new mom on set. And he always was looking out for us. And he said, Ange, do you want one of these orbits? They're pretty amazing. And I said, yeah. And that was my favorite thing about it, too, what you just said. You could pivot and it would lock into place. So if you swiveled it, it could face left, right, front, back, and it would lock into place. Not only was it great when you got your baby out of the car seat, what I loved is you could attach it to the stroller. And let's say you're on a walk and the sun is kind of beating down and you don't want to put the little flap over your baby because your baby wants to be able to see where you're going. You could just pivot so then the baby could look at everything on the right side of the street or everything on the
所以菲尔当时说，它太酷了。如果你想把孩子从车里抱出来而不拆掉安全座椅，你可以旋转它，然后你可以很容易地把孩子从车里抱出来。好吧，詹娜，你知道，菲尔·谢剩下了一些多余的Orbit，而我是片场的新手妈妈。他总是照顾我们。他说，安吉，你想要这些Orbit中的一个吗？它们非常棒。我说，好的。那也是我最喜欢它的地方，就是你刚才说的。你可以旋转它，它会锁定到位。所以如果你旋转它，它可以面向左、右、前、后，并且会锁定到位。不仅在你把孩子从安全座椅里抱出来时很棒，我喜欢的是你可以把它连接到婴儿车上。假设你在散步，太阳有点毒，你不想把小盖子盖在孩子身上，因为你的孩子想看清你要去哪里。你可以直接旋转，这样孩子就可以看到街道右侧的一切，或者……
left side or look at you. It was so great. I love that Phil gave you a stroller and that he gave you a chair from work bus. I know. Do you have any more things? I'm sure I do. Maybe your memory will be jogged as we go along. As we go through the episodes. Well, Phil said that he called Brian on the phone and he was like, listen, I've researched your stroller and I want to put it on the television show, The Office. And he told him the storyline, and Brian agreed to send us 10 strollers. And then Brian flew out and watched the taping. Phil also said the stroller really was indestructible. He's not kidding. There are so many deleted scenes of Rain as Dwight doing things to that stroller. Oh, yeah. The stroller just keeps on trekking. There's way more.
左侧的一切，或者看着你。它太棒了。我喜欢菲尔给了你一辆婴儿车，还给了你一把工作巴士上的椅子。我知道。你还有别的东西吗？我相信我有。也许随着我们继续，你的记忆会被唤起。当我们回顾这些剧集时。好吧，菲尔说他给布莱恩打了电话，他说，听着，我研究了你的婴儿车，我想把它放在电视节目《办公室》里。他告诉了他剧情，布莱恩同意送给我们10辆婴儿车。然后布莱恩飞过来观看了录制。菲尔还说这辆婴儿车确实是坚不可摧的。他没开玩笑。有太多雷恩饰演的德怀特对那辆婴儿车做各种事情的删减片段。哦，是的。婴儿车一直在坚持。还有更多。
Phil told me that one of his favorite things to do was to reach out to these smaller companies that didn't normally do national advertising and feature their products on the show or collaborate with them. And he said another one of the reasons that you saw all of the local foods or the local sodas on the office was because one of our characters is eating like lays potato chips. that could be a conflict with maybe another big national potato chip brand that would have a national commercial running during our show so we weren't allowed. So his choice was he could tape over lays or create a faky chip bag. Right. He said, but what he liked to do was feature products, local products like a hers chip. A smaller company.
菲尔告诉我，他最喜欢做的事情之一就是联系那些通常不做全国广告的小公司，并在节目中展示他们的产品或与他们合作。他说你在《办公室》里看到所有当地食品或当地汽水的另一个原因是因为我们的角色之一在吃乐事薯片，那可能与我们节目期间播放全国商业广告的另一个大型全国薯片品牌产生冲突，所以我们不被允许。所以他的选择是他可以贴掉乐事，或者创造一个假薯片袋。对。他说，但他喜欢做的是展示产品，像赫尔斯薯片这样的当地产品。一家小公司。
That is not going to be in competition for these national spots. And that's another way that he focused in on the orbit. He would try to find these companies that could be approved. Well, I love that because, you know, we love supporting small business. Yeah. Well, the orbit stroller is still available and it is now a big business. I saw online, you can get one at Nordstrom. Well, Jan is done singing.
那不会与这些全国性广告位竞争。这是他关注Orbit的另一种方式。他会试着寻找那些可以被批准的公司。好吧，我喜欢这一点，因为你知道，我们喜欢支持小企业。是的。好吧，Orbit婴儿车仍然有售，现在它是一家大企业了。我在网上看到，你可以在诺德斯特龙买到。好吧，简唱完了。
She's pooped out. I mean, all that singing is going to tire you out. Yeah, she wants to take a nap. She gives the baby to Michael. And she says, when I wake up, I want to talk to you about Astrid's 5-2. Which I looked up. It's like a savings plan for college. Yeah. So what? Michael has to go to all the birthing classes, but he doesn't get to be there for the birth of the baby. And now he's going to contribute to the college fund. That's what it sounds like. Jan needs to go bub-bye. I agree.
她累坏了。我是说，所有的歌唱会让你精疲力竭。是的，她想小睡一会儿。她把孩子给了迈克尔。她说，当我醒来时，我想和你谈谈阿斯特丽德的529计划。我查了一下。这就像是一个大学储蓄计划。是的。所以呢？迈克尔必须参加所有的分娩课程，但他却没能参加孩子的出生。现在他还要为大学基金做贡献。听起来就是这样。简需要说拜拜了。我同意。
Well, Michael only holds the baby for a short time. He's not feeling that connection and he gives the baby to Phyllis. First, Michael has to go to the warehouse. He needs some advice from Daryl. We had a fan question from Ethan B. Did Steve improvise the moment when he asks if he can hold Daryl? They get on this runner where Daryl's like, do you want to hold this? Do you want to hold that? And see if you have a connection, do you want to hold me? No, you guys, that was in the script.
好吧，迈克尔只抱了孩子一会儿。他没感觉到那种联系，就把孩子给了菲利斯。首先，迈克尔必须去仓库。他需要达里尔的一些建议。我们收到了伊森·B的粉丝提问。史蒂夫在问他是否可以抱达里尔时是即兴发挥的吗？他们进入了这个梗，达里尔说，你想抱这个吗？你想抱那个吗？看看你是否有联系，你想抱我吗？不，伙计们，那是剧本里的。
That whole scene was scripted just like that. Well, Jan is still sleeping in the deleted scenes. She's like snoring and everyone's looking at her. She's covered herself with the plastic tablecloth from the shower, and she wakes up and has a pretty amazing exchange with Holly. Where she realizes what we have realized, which is that Holly has a little bit of Michael Scott in her. Yeah. She's making some real Michael Scott jokes here. Yeah.
整个场景就是那样写的。好吧，简在删减片段里还在睡觉。她在打呼噜，每个人都在看着她。她用洗礼上的塑料桌布盖住了自己，她醒来后和霍莉有了一次相当精彩的交流。她意识到我们已经意识到的事情，那就是霍莉身上有一点迈克尔·斯科特的影子。是的。她在这里开了一些真正的迈克尔·斯科特式的玩笑。是的。
And Jan is like, oh, I get it. Funny. Mm-hmm. But Astrid is now with Angela and Andy. I love the scene so much. Angela, please tell me everything about putting. all these vegetables on this baby. All right.
简说，哦，我明白了。有趣。嗯。但阿斯特丽德现在和安吉拉与安迪在一起。我太喜欢这个场景了。安吉拉，请告诉我关于把所有这些蔬菜放在这个婴儿身上的一切。好的。
They had the table completely laid out. They had it all staged. They had the mom with the baby in the wings standing right there. And literally right before action, the mom put the baby down. And then I just put that big, giant fake piece of lettuce on the baby. It was really hard for me because I was a new mom. And I just was like, okay, I just want to do this so fast. I want to do the scene so quickly.
他们把桌子完全布置好了。他们把一切都安排好了。他们让妈妈带着孩子站在侧翼。就在开拍前，妈妈把孩子放下了。然后我就把那片巨大的假生菜放在了孩子身上。这对我来说真的很难，因为我是一个新手妈妈。我当时就想，好的，我只想快点做完。我想尽快完成这个场景。
And then it was so hard for me as a mom to not really connect with the baby at all and just say like, I needed to look up here. Make it look up here. Yes. But it's such a window into Angela. You know, she was a pageant baby. She dresses up her cats. Yes. I feel like her kids are going to be dressed up a lot for all kinds of photos. And Andy is on board. I always imagined that Angela dressed Philip in like the little knee socks and shorts and suspenders with the little Peter Pan collar that you always see little Prince George wearing. That's how I'm. I imagine Philip dresses. Oh yeah. And I also imagine that Angela had like a little sailor suit for him for sure. Sailor hat. A hundred percent. All of that. Yes. Jan comes in as Andy and Angela are having their
作为妈妈，我很难不去和孩子建立联系，只是说，我需要看这里。让它看这里。是的。但这真是了解安吉拉的一个窗口。你知道，她是选美宝宝。她给她的猫打扮。是的。我觉得她的孩子会为了各种照片被盛装打扮。安迪也同意。我一直想象安吉拉给菲利普穿那种小膝袜、短裤和背带，配上你经常看到小乔治王子穿的那种彼得潘领。这就是我想象中菲利普的打扮。哦，是的。我还想象安吉拉肯定给他准备了一套小水手服。水手帽。百分之百。所有这些。是的。当安迪和安吉拉正在进行他们的……
Ann Getty's moment creating this baby salad photo and she is not happy. No, she's irritated and she wants to go. She's done. She's done. She finds Michael in the kitchen and she's ready to go. And Michael, insults Holly again. I guess we've failed to mention that throughout this whole episode, every time Michael, Holly, and Jan are together. Michael just keeps, you know, insulting her. When Holly was going to go into the conference room, he's like, ugh, HR. Now he says she smells like rotten tomatoes. And dirt. And dirt. She smells like tomatoes and dirt. Yeah. And you know what? Jan sees all of it. Jan knows what Michael's doing. And he walks her out to the car. And I, she's putting the baby in the car seat, she turns around. She's like, there is one more thing you could do for me.
安·格迪斯时刻，创造这张婴儿沙拉照片时，简进来了，她很不高兴。不，她很恼火，她想走。她受够了。她受够了。她在厨房找到了迈克尔，准备走了。迈克尔又侮辱了霍莉。我想我们忘了提，在这一整集中，每次迈克尔、霍莉和简在一起时，迈克尔都在不断地侮辱她。当霍莉要进会议室时，他说，呃，人力资源。现在他说她闻起来像烂番茄。还有泥土。还有泥土。她闻起来像番茄和泥土。是的。你知道吗？简看到了这一切。简知道迈克尔在做什么。他把她送到车边。她把孩子放进安全座椅，转过身。她说，你还能为我做一件事。
And he's like, what? And she says, don't date Holly. Yeah. And he's like, why would I hate her? Why would I, you know, and he clearly likes her. Yeah. Jan leaves. She leaves the stroller that was gifted to her. I know. So tacky. So tacky. Tacky, Jan. What was the point of the baby shower? That she could get a nap and maybe get some money out of Michael for a con. college fund. That's what it was. Yeah. Well, Michael is going to go upstairs. And he finds Holly and she says, are you going to still be mean to me? And he just gives her a hug. It's the warmest, most intimate hug. It's so intimate. Amy Ryan is so great. Her eyes just fill with tears. And then Michael has this talking head where he says he didn't feel much when he held Astrid,
他说，什么？她说，别和霍莉约会。是的。他说，我为什么要恨她？我为什么要……你知道，他显然喜欢她。是的。简走了。她留下了送给她的婴儿车。我知道。太俗气了。太俗气了。俗气的简。婴儿洗礼的意义是什么？她可以小睡一会儿，也许能从迈克尔那里弄点钱给大学基金。就是这样。是的。好吧，迈克尔要上楼了。他找到了霍莉，她说，你还要对我刻薄吗？他给了她一个拥抱。这是最温暖、最亲密的拥抱。太亲密了。艾米·瑞安太棒了。她的眼睛里充满了泪水。然后迈克尔有一个独白，他说他抱阿斯特丽德时没感觉，
but he got a good feeling when he held Holly. He asked her out on a date. Mm-hmm. A real official date. She says yes. She sure does. So we're ending with a little love connection there. But now Jim and Pam are both trying to call each other at the same time and they miss each other.
但他抱霍莉时感觉很好。他约她出去约会。嗯。一个正式的约会。她说好。她确实说了好。所以我们以一点爱的联系结束。但现在吉姆和帕姆都在试图同时给对方打电话，他们错过了。
They both go to voicemail at the same time. And I remember Greg talking to me about this scene. I just loved this idea. that we're going to hear each side of their voicemail message, and you're going to see they really are connected. They both recall this same story about the time that, you know, some man came into the laundromat, and Jim had to save Pam, and then they bought a washer dryer. They're recalling this same event. And at the end, they both say, I guess this was just one of those days. I miss you.
他们同时进入了语音信箱。我记得格雷格和我谈过这个场景。我太喜欢这个主意了。我们将听到他们各自的语音留言，你会看到他们确实是相连的。他们都回忆起同一个故事，关于那天，你知道，有个男人走进洗衣店，吉姆不得不救帕姆，然后他们买了一台洗衣机。他们回忆起同一件事。最后，他们都说，我想这只是平常的一天。我想你。
I wish you were home. Yeah. Aaron shared with me that he was just so curious how this scene would turn. turn out because you guys filmed it in two different locations. You didn't have the other person there. No, I couldn't hear John. It was like I was really leaving a message. Yeah. And so you guys were just in this vacuum separate. And then in editing, they were going to find the moment and create it. And he just sort of marveled at how the whole thing came together and just so perfectly. Yes. Well, I had to really imagine in my head as an actor that I was just leaving a message. So in the script, I could see how our
我希望你在家。是的。亚伦告诉我，他很好奇这个场景会变成什么样，因为你们是在两个不同的地点拍摄的。你们没有对方在场。不，我听不到约翰的声音。就像我真的在留言一样。是的。所以你们就在这个真空里分开。然后在剪辑中，他们会找到那个时刻并创造它。他只是惊叹于这一切是如何结合在一起的，而且如此完美。是的。好吧，作为演员，我必须在脑海中真正想象我只是在留言。所以在剧本里，我可以看到我们的……
dialogue was going to alternate and sync up. But I put that out of my mind, and I just did my half without thinking of John's lines in my head at all. Right. And we filmed it like a monologue. Yeah. Well, I loved it. I thought it was really sweet. And it also made me a little sad, because you can tell the distance is starting to take a toll. Yeah. Well, that ends the episode, but Angela, I just realized I skipped a fan question. Okay. And I don't want to leave Evan L. Okay, Evan. Evan wrote in to say at 17 minutes 30 seconds, was that really rain driving around with the stroller tied to the back of the car or was that a stunt driver? Well, we had a stunt driver. His name was Sean Crowder. We also had a stunt coordinator named Wally Crowder. And so
对话本应交替进行并同步。但我把这抛在脑后，只是完成了我那一半，完全没去想约翰的台词。没错。我们把它当作独白来拍。是的。嗯，我很喜欢。我觉得它真的很温馨。但也让我有点难过，因为你能看出距离开始造成影响了。是的。好吧，这集就到这里，但是安吉拉，我刚意识到我漏掉了一个粉丝提问。好的。我不想冷落埃文·L。好的，埃文。埃文写信问，在17分30秒时，真的是雷恩开着车，后面绑着婴儿车吗，还是特技演员开的？嗯，我们有位特技演员。他叫肖恩·克劳德。我们还有一位特技协调员叫沃利·克劳德。所以
Sean did the driving parts. Now, you know, there were some shots of rain inside the car, but the other stuff, that was a stunt driver. Yes. We. We would often do the driving that was just sort of like where you pull up and stop. Yeah. But then if there was like aggressive driving, that's when the stunt driver would take over. Yes. Well, I loved this episode. I thought it was so good and layered with so much heartfelt stuff.
肖恩负责驾驶部分。现在，你知道，车内有一些雷恩的镜头，但其他部分，那是特技演员开的。是的。我们经常会做一些驾驶动作，比如那种靠边停车。是的。但如果有那种激进的驾驶，那就是特技演员接手的时候了。是的。嗯，我很喜欢这一集。我觉得它非常好，充满了许多感人的内容。
And before we say goodbye, I have a little bit of trivia for you. Okay. According to babycenter.com, here are the top girl and boy names in 2008. Oh, from when we did this episode. That's right. Any guesses for the girl? Emma. Yes!
在告别之前，我还有一点小知识要告诉你。好的。根据babycenter.com的数据，这是2008年最受欢迎的女孩和男孩名字。哦，就是我们拍这一集的时候。没错。猜猜女孩的名字是什么？艾玛。是的！
You got it! I was thinking maybe because of the friend's baby. Yes! Rachel had Emma. Really put that name on the map. Guess what the boy name was. I guessed Emma for the girl, like you, but I did not guess right for the boy name. Liam.
你猜对了！我还在想是不是因为《老友记》里的那个宝宝。是的！瑞秋给孩子取名艾玛。确实让这个名字火了起来。猜猜男孩的名字是什么。我像你一样猜了女孩是艾玛，但我没猜对男孩的名字。利亚姆。
Aiden. Aiden. Aidan was the top boy name. Was that from Sex and the City? I don't know. I guessed Jack. Okay. He was in the top five, but Aiden and Emma.
艾登。艾登。艾登是当时最受欢迎的男孩名字。那是来自《欲望都市》吗？我不知道。我猜的是杰克。好吧。他在前五名，但艾登和艾玛是第一。
Well, there it is. You've learned some new baby showers, the Sip and C. Eminem's are still printing names. Yeah, and the orbit stroller's actually really good. And Emma and Aden, 2008 babies, where are you now? I would love it if an Emma and Aden got married. Oh. Well, that was Baby Shower.
好吧，就是这样。你学到了一些新的婴儿派对知识，比如“Sip and See”。M&M豆还在印名字。是的，Orbit婴儿车其实真的很好。还有艾玛和艾登，2008年的宝宝们，你们现在在哪里？如果一个叫艾玛和一个叫艾登的人结婚了，我会很高兴的。哦。好吧，这就是《婴儿派对》这一集。
We'll see you next week. Bye, you guys. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink. episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwolf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Matt Beagle. Our second drinks episodes are produced by Molly Nugent. Our audio engineer is Sam Pfeiffer. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Shultz. Our theme song is Ruppertree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们下周见。再见，大家。感谢收听《办公室女士》的“第二杯”。本集最初是与Earwolf合作制作的。《办公室女士》是Odyssey的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的高级制片人是马特·比格尔。我们的“第二杯”剧集由莫莉·纽金特制作。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·菲佛。Odyssey的执行制片人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《Ruppertree》。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。